Look, there's a rumor going around that I really love seafood. First of all, that's false. I like it. I don't love it, but I like sushi more, but I think what the real rumor was going around that I like women, which is totally not true. Welcome to smart less. Hi. When did you get home?
听着，有个传言说我特别喜欢海鲜。首先，那是假的。我喜欢海鲜，但不至于到爱的程度，我更喜欢寿司。但我认为真正流传的传言是我喜欢女人，这完全不是真的。欢迎来到《SmartLess》。嗨。你什么时候回家的？
Well, I just got back today. Oh my gosh. Yeah, it's really exciting. I had a great time. Thanks for asking. Well, so you still do it old school. You dress up nice for plane flights. Is that right?
嗯，我今天刚回来。天哪。是啊，真的很令人兴奋。我玩得很开心。谢谢你的关心。好吧，所以你还是老派作风。坐飞机时穿得很正式。是这样吗？
Listener, Will's got a nice collar and a v-neck on. I do, actually. You kind of dress up every day anyway. Oh, yeah. Were you flying first class on Panayam or something? Or something, but let me just say. Oh, is that right, eh? Well, you know.
听众朋友们，威尔穿了一件漂亮的衬衫，还戴着V领。确实如此。反正你每天都穿得很正式。哦，是啊。你是坐泛美航空的头等舱还是什么的？或者别的什么，但我只想说。哦，是吗，嗯？好吧，你知道的。
Good for you. I mean. You know, you don't need to dress up for that one. They wait for you. I know, and I do. And you know, I think that you can't coach people up all the time, but you can just model it for them. So I'm just like, I'm trying to set this standard.
为你高兴。我是说。你知道，你不需要为那个穿得那么正式。他们会等你。我知道，我确实会。而且你知道，我认为你不能总是指导别人，但你可以为他们树立榜样。所以我只是想，我正在努力树立这个标准。
I'm like, I'm not going to tell everybody else how to do it. And I'm just going to do it. I'm just lead by example. And I feel like, yeah, it should look nice. I don't see why not. I was, I was in Atlanta, you know, I had a great time. Thanks for asking though. I really did.
我心想，我不会告诉别人该怎么做。我只会自己去做。我只是以身作则。我觉得，是的，看起来应该不错。我不明白为什么不呢。我当时在亚特兰大，你知道，我玩得很开心。不过谢谢你的关心。我真的玩得很开心。
I had a really nice time and it was with all my friends. What were you doing down there? Let's plug some of your stuff. Well, you know, I was working on the, we were making more of these, this Lego program that I like to make. Sure. Most of Lego program. And I also, you do?
我过得非常愉快，而且是和我的朋友们在一起。你在那儿做什么？让我们宣传一下你的东西吧。嗯，你知道，我当时在忙那个，我们在制作更多这样的节目，这个我喜欢做的乐高节目。当然。大部分是乐高节目。而且我也，你做吗？
Sure. Yeah. And I produce it as well. And we have a really fun time down there. Do you drive a GMC when you're down there or eating any Reese's Candies? I was actually, you know, don't, don't tell them I was in a Chevy. Wait, what? That's okay.
当然。是的。而且我也参与制作。我们在那儿玩得很开心。你在那儿的时候开GMC吗，或者吃瑞斯巧克力吗？其实，你知道，别，别告诉他们我开的是雪佛兰。等等，什么？没关系。
It's within the GM family. It's okay. Is it? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And cause GMC and Chevy are both divisions of GM.
那属于通用汽车家族。没关系。是吗？是啊。是啊。是啊。因为GMC和雪佛兰都是通用汽车的部门。
That's enough. That's enough. And I had great meals made by my friend, Brandy. If you're down in Atlanta and you need to. So you're in the Camaro. You're in the Camaro. Was it a five-speed Camaro? It was a suburban.
够了。够了。我吃了我朋友布兰迪做的很棒的饭菜。如果你在亚特兰大，你需要的话。所以你开的是科迈罗。你开的是科迈罗。是五速的科迈罗吗？是萨博班。
Oh, so you weren't driving. You were riding in a Chevy. No, I drove it every day. Oh, yeah. Yeah. I like to, you know, I like to get behind the wheel of a big truck. You had a pull hitch on that suburban, did you? You know, part of the problem is sometimes.
哦，所以你没开车。你坐的是雪佛兰。不，我每天都开。哦，是啊。是啊。我喜欢，你知道，我喜欢坐在一辆大卡车的驾驶座上。你那辆萨博班上有拖车钩，是吗？你知道，问题的一部分是有时候。
Did you wait? Did you, wait, did you, did you, are you done, done? You don't have to go back. You're done. I'm done. I don't have to go back. I remember I came back before. Yeah.
等等，你，等等，你，你，你，你结束了吗？你不用回去了。你结束了。我结束了。我不用回去了。我记得我之前回来过。是啊。
I'm really excited. I'm really excited to be here with you guys. I literally got here this afternoon. I'm so happy. Jason. Somebody loves Los Angeles. And Shawnee, you're back in Los Angeles too. I am too.
我真的很兴奋。我真的很高兴能和你们在一起。我真的是今天下午才到的。我太高兴了。杰森。有人爱洛杉矶。肖恩，你也回洛杉矶了。我也是。
We're all back. We're going to see each other Sunday, maybe. Sunday night where we're doing Sunday Funday. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Did you not even know about this? I just got home.
我们都回来了。我们周日可能会见面。周日晚上我们要搞“周日狂欢”。哦，是啊。是啊。是啊。你甚至不知道这件事吗？我刚到家。
I'm sure Amanda's got a full menu of plans that you've created with her. We did. Will and I share a wife. Let's see. Yeah, it's true. I love that I know before you and Shawn does too. It's so good. Yeah.
我相信阿曼达已经为你制定了完整的计划菜单。我们确实制定了。威尔和我共用一个妻子。让我们看看。是啊，这是真的。我喜欢我比你先知道，肖恩也知道。太棒了。是啊。
Sunday's going to be fun. I can't wait. I'm really excited to see all y'all. Tracy might come. Is that true? Is that right? Yeah. Listen.
周日会很有趣。我等不及了。我真的很兴奋见到你们所有人。特蕾西可能会来。是真的吗？是这样吗？是啊。听着。
No way. Listen, this is significant. Do we have to explain stuff at dinner? Which food is it? What? Well, we're the fork. This is a fork. Yeah.
不会吧。听着，这很重要。我们得在晚餐时解释这些东西吗？这是哪种食物？什么？嗯，我们是叉子。这是一把叉子。是啊。
Jason was making fun of my name before you got on. Will and he was making fun of the menu. They've been misspelling it all these years. It's S-H-A-W-N. And Hayes, everybody knows is H-A-I-S-E. No, but anyways, I had. That's why you're so bad at Quirtle. Quirtle.
在你上线之前，杰森一直在取笑我的名字。威尔，他一直在取笑菜单。他们这些年来一直拼错了。是S-H-A-W-N。海耶斯，大家都知道是H-A-I-S-E。不，但无论如何，我有。这就是为什么你玩《Quirtle》那么烂。Quirtle。
And Quirtle is bigger than Quirtle. No, Shawn. Shawn, we went from Quirtle to Quirtle. I can't do it. I try it. So now we're on a chain with Sam Jones and with Mr. Yes, our friend Matt. Our friend Matt Damon.
而且《Quirtle》比《Quirtle》大。不，肖恩。肖恩，我们从《Quirtle》玩到了《Quirtle》。我做不到。我试过了。所以现在我们和萨姆·琼斯以及马特先生，我们的朋友马特在一起。我们的朋友马特·达蒙。
And Jason struggled with Quirtle. But you know what? We've been gentle on him. We have to Quirtle. Matt and I tied against today. So now we're going, we're now decided that tie break. You have to go to Octortle. Whatever it's called.
杰森在《Quirtle》上挣扎。但你知道吗？我们对他很温柔。我们必须玩《Quirtle》。马特和我今天打平了。所以现在我们决定了，平局决胜。你必须去玩《Octortle》。不管它叫什么。
It's eight. Octortle. It's so stupid. And it gets real chippy in that chain, doesn't it? You've had some good runs, but it gets chippy in there. Will's gifted. Will's, uh, he's surprisingly good at some things you wouldn't think he's good at.
是八个。Octortle。太蠢了。那个链条里火药味很浓，不是吗？你表现不错，但里面火药味很浓。威尔很有天赋。威尔，呃，他在某些你意想不到的事情上出奇地好。
And then shockingly bad at stuff you think he just kind of breathes through, you know, like, uh, driving. I really bad at driving. Sometimes walking. Boy, you put a stick of gum in his mouth and ask him to walk down the street. It's, uh, it's something. No.
然后在一些你觉得他能轻松搞定的事情上又出奇地差，你知道，比如，呃，开车。我开车真的很烂。有时候走路也是。伙计，你往他嘴里塞块口香糖，让他沿着街走。那，呃，那真是绝了。不。
Did you guys, yeah, go ahead. Sean, you were. No, you go. I was going to get to our guest or you were going to get to the guest. Well, they've been waiting for good 45 minutes. No, they haven't. We had a five o'clock record time.
你们，是啊，继续。肖恩，你。不，你先。我本来要介绍我们的嘉宾，或者你要介绍嘉宾。嗯，他们已经等了足足45分钟了。不，他们没有。我们是五点录音。
Will. No, we had. Oh my God. No, he's made me panic. I know the way he does it. By the way, Sean. Yes. Speaking of dressing up, you're wearing a nice shirt today.
威尔。不，我们是。天哪。不，他让我恐慌了。我知道他那种方式。顺便说一句，肖恩。是的。说到穿得正式，你今天穿了一件漂亮的衬衫。
I am. You want to know why I swear to God? Because first of all, let me just say for our listener, no baseball cap and no t-shirt that says like Bob's beer. Yeah. And it's a lavender gingham button up. So clearly what time did mask get out today? Yeah.
我是。你想知道为什么吗？我发誓。因为首先，让我为我们的听众说一下，没有棒球帽，也没有写着“鲍勃啤酒”之类的T恤。是啊。这是一件薰衣草色的格子扣领衬衫。所以很明显，马特今天几点出门的？是啊。
Sean, what happened? And by the way, stand up because I want to see the dockers too. Yeah, no, they are dockers tucked into some pleated khakis. They are dock. They are dock. Cargo pants.
肖恩，怎么了？顺便说一句，站起来，因为我也想看看码头工人的裤子。是啊，不，它们是塞进褶皱卡其裤里的码头工人裤。它们是码头工人裤。它们是码头工人裤。工装裤。
Cargo pants. What happened? Did you unlock a time capsule for 1998? Does it have a loop for the hammer? I was just playing Uncharted. No, I swear to God, I did not make this up. I woke up today and I saw my sweats and my shorts. I was like, gosh, I wear that every day.
工装裤。怎么了？你打开了1998年的时间胶囊吗？它有挂锤子的环吗？我刚才在玩《神秘海域》。不，我发誓，我不是编的。我今天醒来，看到我的运动裤和短裤。我心想，天哪，我每天都穿那个。
Even to parties. Yeah, even to parties. And then I was like, you know what? Poor Scotty never sees me dressed as a human being. So for Scotty today, I dressed in a nice shirt and just regular pants. Just to kick around the house and eat your tuna fish sandwiches?
甚至去参加派对也穿。是啊，甚至去派对。然后我就想，你知道吗？可怜的斯科蒂从来没见过我像个人一样穿衣服。所以为了斯科蒂，今天我穿了一件漂亮的衬衫和普通的裤子。只是为了在家里走动，吃你的金枪鱼三明治？
Yeah, totally. By the way, not even kidding, had a tuna fish sandwich today and a little bit of spaghetti. Of course, not kidding. There's nothing kidding about that. Yeah, this is very serious business, dude. Anyway, thank you for noticing. You look great.
是啊，完全是。顺便说一句，不开玩笑，今天吃了一个金枪鱼三明治和一点意大利面。当然，不开玩笑。那没什么好开玩笑的。是啊，这是非常严肃的事情，伙计。无论如何，谢谢你的注意。你看起来很棒。
So that's just your kick around outfit today. That's my kick around outfit today. I mean, that's stuff to do, but yeah. And is this the same haircut from 12 days ago from Scandal? Oh, I thought you were going to say. Yes, it is. Oh, it is.
所以那只是你今天的居家装扮。那是我今天的居家装扮。我是说，还有事情要做，但确实。这是12天前《丑闻》里的同一个发型吗？哦，我以为你要说。是的，是。哦，是啊。
It's getting long, right? It's getting a little long on top there. I'm going to have a question. Can we come in for your next sesh? What's his name? What's his name again? It's Skevo. Skevo.
变长了，对吧？头顶有点长了。我有个问题。我们能去参加你的下一次理发吗？他叫什么名字？他叫什么名字来着？是Skevo。Skevo。
I'm not Skevo if you're listening. I'm not laughing at you. I just appreciate the salon name. I know. Wait a minute, Jason. It's the same salon you go to. I just go to a different guy. Yeah, but my guy's name is Chris.
如果你们在听，我不是Skevo。我不是在嘲笑你。我只是欣赏这个沙龙的名字。我知道。等等，杰森。这是你去的那家沙龙。我只是找不同的人剪。是啊，但我那个人叫克里斯。
You know, like, it's Skevo. You can't do anything but cut hair with a name like Skevo. Jason, let me ask you. Did Chris break both his hands? No, no, no. No, no. No, no.
你知道，就像，是Skevo。叫Skevo这种名字，除了剪头发什么也干不了。杰森，让我问你。克里斯把双手都弄断了吗？不，不，不。不，不。不，不。
No, no. No, no. Did he break both his hands? What's going on? Is he not? Listen, I've got some real growth going on. I actually kind of like the long hair. It's not great.
不，不。不，不。他把双手都弄断了吗？怎么回事？他不是吗？听着，我的头发长得很快。其实我有点喜欢长发。不太好。
It's not great. We'll let our guest weigh in on this, but I need the hat, at least. All right, let's get to it. Let's go. Let's go with this guest. Here we go. Our guest today is a pretty major guest.
不太好。我们会让我们的嘉宾对此发表意见，但我至少需要那顶帽子。好了，让我们开始吧。走吧。让我们开始介绍这位嘉宾。我们开始吧。我们今天的嘉宾是一位非常重要的嘉宾。
I think you'll be impressed. I'm so excited he agreed to do this. The man is hilarious. And just when we thought he couldn't get more successful and at the top of his game, his career became a marvel. And everything shifted for this handsome, funny man, which is usually an oxymoron. He's so clearly one of the most sought after actors
我想你会印象深刻的。我很高兴他同意参加。这个人非常搞笑。就在我们以为他不可能更成功、处于事业巅峰时，他的职业生涯变成了一个奇迹。一切都为这个英俊、风趣的男人改变了，这通常是一个矛盾修辞。他显然是好莱坞最抢手的演员之一，
in Hollywood starring in Blockbuster. But most important above all, he's also one of the kindest, most humblest men I've ever known. So we really aren't worthy. But regardless, welcome to smartless Christopher Pratt. Chris Pratt. I knew I had it with the Chris. Damn it.
主演大片。但最重要的是，他也是我认识的最善良、最谦逊的人之一。所以我们真的不配。但无论如何，欢迎来到《SmartLess》，克里斯托弗·普拉特。克里斯·普拉特。我知道我用克里斯是对的。该死。
Are you serious? I know. Oh boy. Now, Sean, you and I are going to have to just take a seat and let these two. I know. Because they love each other so much. They went to space camp.
你是认真的吗？我知道。哦，伙计。现在，肖恩，你和我得坐下来，让这两个人。我知道。因为他们太爱对方了。他们去过太空营。
But we were just talking about him coming on this show. And that's why I know. Well, Will, why didn't you invite him? I mean, Chris. I know. Why didn't you invite me? What's wrong with you, Will? Oh my god.
但我们刚才还在谈论他来这个节目。这就是为什么我知道。好吧，威尔，你为什么不邀请他？我是说，克里斯。我知道。你为什么不邀请我？你怎么了，威尔？哦，天哪。
This is such a, and I just checked in with Michael recently and I was like, what's going on with Pratt? He's like, it's going to happen. Let me just get back. I'm like, OK. This is like, OK. Sean and I are just fascinated. I'm happy you're here.
这真是，我最近刚和迈克尔确认过，我问普拉特怎么回事。他说，会发生的。让我回去。我说，好的。这就像，好的。肖恩和我只是着迷了。我很高兴你在这里。
I'm happy I'm here. Hi, Chris. I'm like, hi, guys. I love that man we're talking to right now named Chris Pratt. And I don't know if you guys know, but I'm really close. I've known his wife, Catherine, for decades, literally decades since she was a child. So I feel like she's my little sister.
我很高兴我在这里。嗨，克里斯。我心想，嗨，伙计们。我喜欢我们现在正在谈论的那个叫克里斯·普拉特的男人。我不知道你们知不知道，但我真的很亲近。我认识他的妻子凯瑟琳几十年了，真的是几十年，从她还是个孩子的时候起。所以我感觉她就像我的小妹妹。
Great story. Chris, welcome to the show. Look, you've got a collar on too. I know. Yeah, why do you look so nice, Chris? We are wrapping up. This is what I was, you know, wearing today. Eating tuna for sandwiches?
好故事。克里斯，欢迎来到节目。看，你也戴着领子。我知道。是啊，克里斯，你为什么看起来这么帅？我们要结束了。这就是我今天穿的。吃金枪鱼三明治？
For work. I was doing some Pratt stuff, so they had me dressed up. If you've ever seen me dress nice, it's because I did something for work. Now, is this a junket? Is this a junket outfit or a photography session outfit or a talk show? This?
为了工作。我做了一些普拉特的事情，所以他们让我穿得很正式。如果你见过我穿得很漂亮，那是因为我为了工作做了些什么。现在，这是新闻发布会吗？这是新闻发布会装扮，还是摄影环节装扮，还是脱口秀？这个？
What did we do today? I did a talk show. I did the Kelly Clarkson show. Sure. All right. And how was that? It was great. We did it with the whole cast of, well,
我们今天做了什么？我参加了一个脱口秀。我参加了凯莉·克拉克森秀。当然。好的，那怎么样？很棒。我们和整个剧组一起，嗯，
a bunch of the cast members from Jurassic World. Jurassic World Dominion, you mean? Not from Jurassic World. What is that? Is that some sort of? That was good. That was really good. That was a good save by my brother.
《侏罗纪世界》的一群演员。你是说《侏罗纪世界3：统治》？不是《侏罗纪世界》。那是什么？那是什么？那很好。那真的很好。我兄弟救场救得好。
Wait a minute. Let me tell you something. I watched that movie and I was blown away. That is an incredible ride. It's so great. I'm so glad you said away. I'm so glad you said away. It was blown period.
等等。让我告诉你一件事。我看了那部电影，我被震撼了。那是一次不可思议的旅程。太棒了。我很高兴你说震撼了。我很高兴你说震撼了。那是震撼句号。
I was like, where did you see the movie? Why do you think I dressed up for that? I saw all of it. My friend, however, missed a large chunk of it. Universal is loving this. Universal is so happy. It's the kind of family content. No.
我心想，你在哪里看的电影？你以为我为什么穿得那么正式？我全看了。然而，我的朋友错过了很大一部分。环球影业喜欢这个。环球影业太高兴了。这是那种家庭内容。不。
It is so good, Chris. I hope you're proud of it because it's fucking amazing. It's so great. I am. It is really good. It's a great progression from the previous movie. It just keeps getting better and better. What's nice is the whole cast from Jurassic Park is back in this movie.
这太棒了，克里斯。我希望你为此感到自豪，因为它他妈的太棒了。太棒了。我是。这真的很好。这是上一部电影的伟大进步。它只会越来越好。好的是《侏罗纪公园》的整个剧组都回到了这部电影中。
Yes. To see you guys together was so cool. This is Sam Neal and Jeff Goldblum and Laura Dern. Laura Dern, Beaty Wong. Were all the dinosaurs available? Many of the same dinosaurs came back. Could make their deals. It's not just actors.
是的。看到你们在一起真是太酷了。这是萨姆·尼尔、杰夫·高布伦和劳拉·邓恩。劳拉·邓恩，黄荣亮。所有的恐龙都有空吗？许多相同的恐龙回来了。能达成交易。不仅仅是演员。
Unbelievable. I want to ask you something, Chris. When someone is as massively successful as you and you know, you know. Last question, Sean. Oh, I'm sorry. No, that's fine. Then you got to go. Last question already.
难以置信。我想问你一件事，克里斯。当一个人像你一样极其成功时，你知道，你知道。最后一个问题，肖恩。哦，对不起。不，没关系。那你得走了。已经是最后一个问题了。
Fuck. No, no, sorry. Go ahead. Sorry. I have to speed things up. No, when someone is as hugely successful as you and you know, you know every time you open a movie that it's going to be seen by the world. Do you ever go, damn, all my hard work paid off?
操。不，不，对不起。继续。对不起。我得加快速度。不，当一个人像你一样极其成功时，你知道，你知道每次你上映一部电影，全世界都会看到。你有没有想过，该死，我所有的努力都得到了回报？
Are you aware enough to embrace your own success? Can you enjoy it? Are you like push it away? Deflect. Oh, man. You can't win answering this question. This is what Sean does. Why not?
你有足够的意识去拥抱自己的成功吗？你能享受它吗？你是不是像把它推开？转移话题。哦，伙计。回答这个问题你赢不了。这就是肖恩做的。为什么不？
He puts all the praise and then he drops a bomb on you that you can't win. And then he says, Chris, please walk into Douche Town. I want you to walk into Douche Town. Join me. I want you to say something about yourself that makes everyone think that you're a complete asshole. No, no, no. Sean, why don't you ask him how many times a day he Googles himself, okay?
他把所有的赞美都放在那里，然后他扔给你一个你无法获胜的炸弹。然后他说，克里斯，请走进“混蛋镇”。我希望你走进“混蛋镇”。加入我。我希望你说一些关于你自己的话，让每个人都认为你是个彻头彻尾的混蛋。不，不，不。肖恩，你为什么不问他一天谷歌自己多少次，好吗？
I'll answer that for myself. No, no, I was asking because it's like a healthy thing to say. Yes, I'm proud of what I've done. Like it's okay to say that. I think it's so amazing that you're such a gigantic global star now and from where you came that you should feel proud because you have worked so hard. So I'll say it for you. Amen.
我会为自己回答这个问题。不，不，我问是因为这是一种健康的事情。是的，我为我所做的一切感到自豪。说出来没关系。我觉得你现在是一个如此巨大的全球明星，从你来的地方，你应该感到自豪，因为你工作得太努力了。所以我为你说了。阿门。
There it is. I will second that. That's so nice. Yeah. I mean, look, I feel, I feel like definitely like blessed and grateful. I've got an awesome manager who forces me to say no to things that I would absolutely say yes to if it weren't for my manager. So like I have, it's like the result of really great discernment on my team.
就是这样。我附议。太好了。是啊。我是说，看，我感觉，我绝对感觉像被祝福和感激。我有一个很棒的经理，他强迫我对那些我本来绝对会说“是”的事情说“不”，如果不是因为我的经理的话。所以就像我有，这是我团队中非常好的洞察力的结果。
It's definitely a team effort. And I've been lucky enough to hitch my, you know, wagon to these titles that were really, really special and big titles with Marvel and with Jurassic World. So it's like, you know, and not to deflect or anything like that. Like definitely proud of my contribution to them, but these are, these were like juggernauts that I was lucky enough to jump on. And so like it's been an awesome. But you would definitely not, hold on, Will, you would definitely not shy away from something
这绝对是团队合作。而且我很幸运能把我的，你知道，马车挂在这些非常、非常特别的大片上，比如漫威和《侏罗纪世界》。所以就像，你知道，不是为了转移话题什么的。绝对为我对它们的贡献感到自豪，但这些是，这些是像我幸运地跳上的巨头。所以就像，这已经是一个很棒的。但你绝对不会，等等，威尔，你绝对不会回避某件事
that was fully dependent on you though, right? Without, without any sort of like, you'd go off, do some original one act in an equity waiver theater. Would you not? We got him. Oh, immediately. Yeah. Yeah.
那完全取决于你，对吧？没有，没有那种，你会离开，去演一些原创的独幕剧，在公平豁免剧院。你会吗？我们抓住他了。哦，立刻。是啊。是啊。
It would have to be the right. It would have to be the right. The right time of the year. Why? What do you have? And go for Will. I was just noticing that you all, you were saying you were really grateful and blessed and you kind of at first had your glass and I was like, that's a great, you created
那必须是正确的。那必须是正确的。一年中正确的时间。为什么？你有什么？去吧，威尔。我只是注意到你们，你说你真的很感激和被祝福，你一开始有你的玻璃杯，我心想，那是一个伟大的，你创造了
a nice word, which is grateful and I feel really blessed. Oh, that's right. It's a mashup. Or personally, I'm blade. I am. Glast would be really good. Glast would save you a lot of time. You know what I mean?
一个很好的词，就是感激和被祝福。哦，那是对的。这是一个混搭。或者就我个人而言，我是“Glast”。我是。Glast会很好。Glast会为你节省很多时间。你知道我的意思吗？
It's like if you didn't have to say grateful and blessed for all the times you're forced to say that. Think of all the time. I first fell in love with Chris Pratt when he was nice enough to do our little chat and giggle for, I believe it was Denny's one. Will and I were running a digital ad agency for about three seconds. And we came up with some, what? Do you remember that?
就像如果你不必在所有被迫说的时候说感激和被祝福。想想所有的时间。我第一次爱上克里斯·普拉特是因为他足够好，愿意和我们聊天和傻笑，我相信那是丹尼的那个。威尔和我经营一家数字广告代理公司大约三秒钟。我们想出了一些，什么？你记得那个吗？
I do. With Kekner? With Kekner. Yeah. Were you on Parks and Recs at the time or before? I think you were, weren't you? I think it was Parks and Rec. Yeah.
我记得。和Kekner一起？和Kekner一起。是啊。你当时在《公园与游憩》还是之前？我想你在，不是吗？我想那是《公园与游憩》。是啊。
I think it might have been Parks and Rec or around then. Yeah. Yeah, it was Parks and Rec. And what happened was, first of all, I fell in love with Pratt because when he first did that first season of Parks and Rec and I started to watch the cuts of the show and Amy will back me up on this, I was watching the episodes and I was like, who the fuck is this guy? This guy is fucking hilarious. He played Andy.
我想那可能是《公园与游憩》或者那时候。是啊。是啊，那是《公园与游憩》。发生的事情是，首先，我爱上了普拉特，因为当他第一次做《公园与游憩》的第一季时，我开始看节目的剪辑，艾米会支持我这一点，我在看剧集，我心想，这他妈是谁？这家伙他妈的太搞笑了。他演安迪。
He was Rashida's boyfriend. He had a broken leg. He was a good for nothing dude. Like stuck at home making her do shit for him. And she was like, oh God, dating this loser guy. And he was so funny, so effortlessly funny. I was like, this guy's fucking it. And Will doesn't give it up for a lot, Chris.
他是拉什达的男朋友。他腿断了。他是个一无是处的家伙。就像困在家里让她为他做烂事。而她就像，哦天哪，和这个失败的家伙约会。他太搞笑了，毫不费力地搞笑。我心想，这家伙他妈的太棒了。威尔不会轻易放弃很多，克里斯。
That's high praise. I don't know. Pratt, well, he knows. He knows how much I love him. And then Pratt did one of the funniest things I've ever seen. I saw him on Conan years ago, early on. You probably don't remember this. And you go, you get at one point, you're talking to Conan, and then you stood up and you start
那是高度赞扬。我不知道。普拉特，嗯，他知道。他知道我有多爱他。然后普拉特做了我见过的最搞笑的事情之一。我多年前在柯南秀上见过他，很早的时候。你可能不记得了。然后你走，你在某个时候，你在和柯南说话，然后你站起来，你开始
to take your jacket off. And Conan goes, what are you doing? You go, I'm hot. And nobody ever does that on a talk show. I thought you were going to say that he just collapsed on the ground. And then he said, what are you doing? And he said, I just did a Pratt fall. That would have killed.
脱掉你的夹克。柯南说，你在做什么？你说，我很热。从来没有人会在脱口秀上那样做。我以为你要说他只是倒在地上。然后他说，你在做什么？他说，我刚做了一个普拉特摔。那会杀人的。
For me, it was funnier that he just took his jacket off. And then he was relaxed. And I thought, this son of a gun. It's a different beat. Chris, why are you so relaxed on those shows? Why are you so relaxed? What's the name of the pharmaceutical? Do you shoot at the back of your knee?
对我来说，他只是脱掉夹克更搞笑。然后他放松了。我心想，这个小兔崽子。这是一个不同的节奏。克里斯，为什么你在那些节目上那么放松？为什么你那么放松？那个药物的名字是什么？你是在膝盖后面注射的吗？
Or is it just a tablet? I heard someone today was talking about that they were like, I asked someone, I said, do you get nervous before you go through this? And someone had mentioned, oh, I'd take a, what did they say? There was some pill that they took. There's like, I take it this. It was like a, I don't know if there was like a name. Beta blocker, like a beta blocker.
还是只是药片？我今天听到有人在谈论那个，他们就像，我问某人，我说，你在经历这个之前会紧张吗？有人提到，哦，我吃一个，他们说什么？有一些药片他们吃了。就像，我吃这个。就像一个，我不知道是否有一个名字。β受体阻滞剂，就像β受体阻滞剂。
A blocker, a blocker. A beta blocker, yeah. A beta blocker. Look at the acting skills on Chris. He just, he seems like he's never heard of these things, you know? Like what's the- A beta blocker? Yeah dude, Chris, by the way, that's the real thing is I take a beta blocker every time around
阻滞剂，阻滞剂。β受体阻滞剂，是啊。β受体阻滞剂。看看克里斯的演技。他只是，他看起来好像从来没听说过这些东西，你知道吗？就像什么- β受体阻滞剂？是啊伙计，克里斯，顺便说一句，那是真实的事情，我每次在
Bateman and then I can't hear him. It blocks about. It blocks out all the betas. A beta blocker. Yeah, that's a machine. He's calling me a beta and it's the beta thing, Sean. It's even more hard. But like, I don't feel, like I've never had, I don't know, I think I have natural beta
贝特曼周围都吃β受体阻滞剂，然后我就听不到他的声音了。它阻断了大约。它阻断了所有的β。β受体阻滞剂。是啊，那是一台机器。他在叫我β，这是β的事情，肖恩。这更难。但就像，我不觉得，就像我从来没有，我不知道，我想我有天然的β
blockers in my head. What do you get, what do you get nervous about? Golf. I know you're a great golfer, so probably not that. Golf. No. I'm a complete head case in golf. Really?
阻滞剂在我的脑子里。你因为什么感到紧张？高尔夫。我知道你是个伟大的高尔夫球手，所以可能不是那个。高尔夫。不。我在高尔夫上是个彻头彻尾的疯子。真的吗？
Really? Yeah. It messes my whole game up. I can't just go and like, you know, some of those guys are like, ah. Because the thing is, I'm not as good at golf as I am at like going on a talk show. You know what I mean? If I was as good at golf as I was, like just sitting down at a talk show and shooting the shit and making me-
真的吗？是啊。它搞砸了我整场比赛。我不能只是去，你知道，那些家伙中的一些人就像，啊。因为问题是，我在高尔夫上不如我在脱口秀上那么好。你知道我的意思吗？如果我像在脱口秀上坐下来聊天、胡扯和让我-
Well, what kind of golfer are you? Mid-80s, mid-90s? I'm like a 14. Yeah, there you go. That's great. It's not great. It should be better. For the amount of time and effort I put in, I can't tell you how many times I'll be on
好吧，你是什么样的高尔夫球手？80多杆，90多杆？我像个14杆。是啊，就是这样。太棒了。不太好。应该更好。对于我投入的时间和精力，我无法告诉你我会有多少次在
the golf course and I'll legit go, you know what, fucking fuck this fucking game. Right. I quit. What am I doing? What am I doing? I'm spending all my time doing this and this is only how good I am? Why? I could have written a book.
高尔夫球场上，我会合法地去，你知道吗，他妈的去他妈的这个他妈的游戏。对。我退出了。我在做什么？我在做什么？我花了我所有的时间做这个，而这就是我有多好？为什么？我本可以写一本书。
I could have gotten a degree. I could have done anything with my fucking life. And then I get a good shot. I'm like, yeah, baby. Yeah, baby. That is back. So that's like the emotional roller coaster. I know.
我本可以拿到学位。我本可以用我他妈的生活做任何事。然后我打了一个好球。我心想，是啊，宝贝。是啊，宝贝。那又回来了。所以那就像情感过山车。我知道。
Chris, I'll tell you what though. One time, a couple of months ago, we were playing golf. Jason and I were playing golf and we saw a couple of guys at the place we were playing. It was before the LA, the, the Genesis. Yeah. And we saw a couple of pros playing and I was having a bad day. And these guys, we saw a DJ and a couple of guys having a practice round and Jason points up to them on, they're on a different hole.
克里斯，我告诉你一件事。有一次，几个月前，我们在打高尔夫。杰森和我在打高尔夫，我们在我们打球的地方看到了几个家伙。那是在洛杉矶，那个，那个创世纪之前。是啊，我们看到几个职业选手在打球，我那天过得很糟糕。这些家伙，我们看到DJ和几个家伙在练习，杰森指着他们，他们在不同的洞。
And he, and he, and he says to me, just to give me a perspective, cause I was in a bad place and he goes, they can't do what you do. And I went, oh yeah. You're a professional at something completely different. Yeah. You're an amateur at what you're a pro at. Yeah. And I was like, okay.
他，他，他对我说，只是为了给我一个视角，因为我处于一个糟糕的地方，他说，他们做不到你做的事。我心想，哦，是啊。你是完全不同事情的专业人士。是啊。你是你擅长的事情的业余爱好者。是啊。我心想，好的。
And it, and it put it in perspective and Jason hats off. It made the rest of my day quite pleasant. So thank you. That's nice. You helped my experience. I love you. When you give back, when I give to you and you give back to me, I love that. That's pretty cool.
而且，它把视角放正了，杰森脱帽致敬。它让我的余生过得很愉快。所以谢谢你。那很好。你帮助了我的经历。我爱你。当你回馈，当我给你，你回馈给我时，我喜欢那样。那很酷。
Jason usually tells me, I can't do anything. You're an amateur at everything. Now get in the car. And now a word from our sponsor. And now back to the show. Let me ask you this. I've never, I've never known. I know that before parks and rec, you were doing a sort of a show.
杰森通常告诉我，我什么都做不了。你什么都是业余的。现在上车。现在是我们的赞助商的话。现在回到节目。让我问你这个。我从来没有，我从来没有知道。我知道在《公园与游憩》之前，你在做一个节目。
You were doing a much more serious show. Right. What was the name of the show you did before for a couple years? I did a TV show. Well, it was like a teen drama. It was called everwood. It was on the WB. Everwood.
你在做一个更严肃的节目。对。你在之前做了几年的节目叫什么名字？我做了一个电视节目。嗯，就像一个青少年剧。它叫《雪山镇》。它在WB上。雪山镇。
So not a comment. One of the, one of my early claims of fame was that Sean Hayes made an everwood joke on willing grace. And we all thought that we made it. He was like, I'm going to stay at home and have everwood with my date or something like that. Like that was the joke was like everwood, like an everlasting boner. I think you had an everwood watching, watching Jurassic the other day.
所以不是评论。我早期的成名作之一是肖恩·海耶斯在《威尔与格蕾丝》中开了一个《雪山镇》的玩笑。我们都以为我们成功了。他说，我要待在家里和我的约会对象看《雪山镇》之类的。就像那个笑话是像《雪山镇》，就像一个永恒的勃起。我想你那天看《侏罗纪》的时候有一个《雪山镇》。
Right. Wow. Do you, I love the sound effects. So Chris, but that show, not a comedy. Right. What was the, what was the first, I mean, God, I, I didn't know you've gone on. You've done lots of different stuff and you've done action. You've done stuff that's more intense or whatever.
对。哇。你，我喜欢音效。所以克里斯，但那个节目，不是喜剧。对。什么是，什么是第一个，我是说，天哪，我，我不知道你已经走了。你做了很多不同的事情，你做了动作片。你做了更激烈的事情之类的。
But for me, I feel like you've got such a comedic heart, which I love. It's so rare. Like in my little intro, I really mean that. Like good looks with comedy is so rare. Yeah. Oh guys. Thank you. Fun.
但对我来说，我觉得你有一个喜剧的心，我喜欢。太罕见了。就像在我的小介绍里，我是认真的。就像好看和喜剧太罕见了。是啊。哦，伙计们。谢谢。有趣。
Who are you talking to? I can't tell who you're looking at on this show. I'm sorry. I can't see. I was looking in a mirror. Just off the side. I have a mirror set up in my, you forgot you were doing the show. Now Chris, I know you're too humble to really address this question, but if you were to
你在和谁说话？我看不出你在节目中看着谁。对不起。我看不见。我是在照镜子。就在旁边。我在我的地方放了一面镜子，你忘了你在做节目。现在克里斯，我知道你太谦虚了，无法真正解决这个问题，但如果你要
concede that you are affable and good looking and approachable and an everyman, would you blame that on your dad, your mom? You got a brother who's like that. Like where, where, where'd you, where'd you get it from? Where'd you get it? I think, you know, growing up with my family, just we were talking about this will when it lands together, the love language is just legit burns, you know, cutting each other up, like, like insult love.
承认你和蔼可亲、长相英俊、平易近人且是一个普通人，你会把那归咎于你的父亲、你的母亲吗？你有一个像那样的兄弟。就像哪里，哪里，哪里你得到的？你从哪里得到的？我想，你知道，和我的家人一起长大，我们刚才在谈论这个，威尔，当它一起着陆时，爱的语言就是合法的烧伤，你知道，互相切割，就像，就像侮辱爱。
You know what I mean? Where you kind of just say gloves are off. I will absolutely allow you to say anything you want to try to cut me down and I'll appreciate what you do for its humor. And you know, like no one gets their feelings hurt and always, always has their feelings hurt a little bit. Yeah. Exactly.
你知道我的意思吗？你只是说手套脱了。我绝对会允许你说任何你想说的话来试图削减我，我会因为它的幽默而欣赏你所做的。而且你知道，就像没有人会受伤，总是，总是会有一点受伤。是啊。完全正确。
It thickens your skin. Yeah. You're just not allowed to take yourself too seriously. I think that's it. I think it's like, you know, appreciating comedy and just, just getting the piss taken out of you. Right. But for, but for people who don't know, and I think Will was kind of hinting at this
它让你的皮肤变厚。是啊。你只是不允许把自己看得太重。我想就是这样。我想就像，你知道，欣赏喜剧，只是，只是被尿尿。对。但对于，但对于不知道的人，我想威尔有点暗示这一点
is like, I'm sure you're sick of talking about this, but you worked at Bubba Gump Shrimp and Maui while you were homeless, which is like blows my mind. Wait, that's news to me. Me too. How did you end up in Maui? Well, I, after I, I didn't go to college and I, you know, I did like a semester of community college that I was like paying for myself and just hated it. Shrimp?
就像，我相信你厌倦了谈论这个，但你在无家可归时在毛伊岛的阿甘虾餐厅工作，这就像让我大吃一惊。等等，这对我是新闻。我也是。你怎么最终去了毛伊岛？嗯，我，在我，我没有上大学，而且我，你知道，我做了像一个学期的社区大学，我是在为自己付钱，只是讨厌它。虾？
No, no, no, this is before the shrimp. Because I, you know, I graduated, I was young, I was 17 when I graduated. I had done sports through school. So I never did any plays. However, I was always MCing, writing and kind of producing our assemblies at school following my brother's footsteps. He had done the same thing. So I really loved the showmanship and doing these song and dance numbers and like comedy
不，不，不，这是在虾之前。因为我，你知道，我毕业了，我很年轻，我毕业时才17岁。我在学校里做过运动。所以我从来没有演过任何戏。然而，我一直在MC，写作，并有点制作我们在学校的集会，追随我哥哥的脚步。他也做了同样的事情。所以我真的很喜欢表演欲，做这些歌舞表演，就像喜剧
sketches in front of the school and stuff, really kind of scoring with that stuff. I did stand-up comedy right after high school. I did a community play right after high school. Started doing several plays at this local theater. So I knew I had the bug that I wanted to be a performer, but it seemed outrageous to me. I became a door-to-door salesman and I did that job for, yeah, I did that job for about, I mean, probably a little over a year, maybe a year and a half. How old?
在学校面前的素描之类的，真的有点用那些东西得分。我高中毕业后立刻做了单口喜剧。我高中毕业后做了一个社区剧。开始在当地剧院做几部戏。所以我知道我有虫子，我想成为一个表演者，但这对我来说似乎很离谱。我成了一个上门推销员，我做了那份工作，是啊，我做了那份工作大约，我是说，可能一年多一点，也许一年半。多大？
I was, you know, from the time I was 18 to about almost 20. What were you selling? I was selling these coupons. So like businesses in the service industry, such as a Minakie or a Midas or maybe like even a salon would put together this like package of like, you know, bring your car in, you'd get oil changes. Four oil changes for $20 was the deal, but really we would sell it to the person and they would take their car and get free oil changes.
我是，你知道，从我18岁到快20岁。你在卖什么？我在卖这些优惠券。所以就像服务行业的企业，比如Minakie或Midas，或者甚至像沙龙之类的，会把这个像包裹一样放在一起，就像，你知道，把你的车开进来，你会得到换油。20美元换四次换油是交易，但实际上我们会把它卖给那个人，他们会把他们的车开去得到免费换油。
But really the mechanic would try to like upsell them on a break job or something like that. So it was like this is a coupon kind of a thing. It's criminal in nature basically, right? No, you just sold me. It was a little bit of a pyramid scheme. Good. It was kind of, yeah. It was like these multi-level marketing things were like, you know, I was a, first of all,
但实际上机械师会试图像向他们推销刹车工作之类的东西。所以就像这是一个优惠券之类的东西。本质上是犯罪的，对吧？不，你只是卖给我。这有点像金字塔计划。好。它有点，是啊。它就像这些多层次营销的东西，就像，你知道，我是一个，首先，
zero critical thinking skills were ever taught to anyone in my household. My mom was a checker at Safeway for 29 years. She'd literally believe anything anyone told her through her life. She's still that way. We bless her hard. And so I answered an ad in the paper for this door-to-door sales thing that said, do you like rock and roll music? Do you want to make money?
零批判性思维技能在我的家庭中被教给任何人。我妈妈在Safeway做了29年的检查员。她真的会相信任何人在她一生中告诉她的任何事情。她仍然是那样。我们祝福她的心。所以我回答了报纸上关于这个上门推销东西的广告，上面写着，你喜欢摇滚乐吗？你想赚钱吗？
And I was like, oh my God, I think this might be it. I think this might be it. Well, I've posted those things. And it was that. And so for a year I did this door-to-door sales job. And after I opened my own office in Colorado, like climbed to the top. I've got all the sales awards and won a free trip to Jamaica. I did very well at this job.
我心想，哦，天哪，我想这可能是它。我想这可能是它。嗯，我贴了那些东西。就是那样。所以一年我做了这份上门推销工作。在我自己在科罗拉多州开了自己的办公室后，就像爬到了顶峰。我得到了所有的销售奖，并赢得了去牙买加的免费旅行。我在这份工作上做得很好。
But then I got totally burnt out and learned that my management skills were terrible. I was just really good at selling shit. And so when I tried to open my own office and I put the same ad in the paper, it turned out only ding-dongs would answer. And the guy's like, I like that. I was like, cool, let's go, let's get excited. And they're like, I don't really, I forgot my shoes or whatever. Why is there just like scraping the bottom of the unemployment barrel?
但后来我完全精疲力竭，了解到我的管理技能很糟糕。我只是真的很擅长卖烂东西。所以当我试图开自己的办公室，我把同样的广告放在报纸上时，结果只有叮当声才会回答。那个家伙就像，我喜欢那个。我心想，酷，走吧，让我们兴奋起来。他们就像，我真的不，我忘了我的鞋子之类的。为什么只有像刮失业桶底的人？
Wait, what were the two questions? Holy shit. Do you like rock and roll and like to have fun or like to make money? Do you want, do you like rock and roll music? Do you want to make money? I mean, that's going to solicit some real questionable. Wait, so why did hindsight? It wasn't the best ad, but I was the guy who answered that ad.
等等，那两个问题是什么？天哪。你喜欢摇滚乐和喜欢玩还是喜欢赚钱？你想要，你喜欢摇滚乐吗？你想赚钱吗？我是说，那会招揽一些真正可疑的。等等，所以为什么事后诸葛亮？这不是最好的广告，但我就是那个回答那个广告的人。
So I thought that's effective. There's probably a bunch of like... It netted me. Yeah. Scooped you right up. It reminds me of that line. Remember in Idiocracy when the guy says to Dax, I like money? He goes, I like money too.
所以我认为那是有效的。可能有一堆像... 它网住了我。是啊。把你舀起来了。这让我想起了那句台词。记得在《蠢蛋进化论》里，当那个家伙对Dax说，我喜欢钱？他说，我也喜欢钱。
I mean, what it really does is the true brilliance in it is it filters out people who are too critical of critical thinkers, you know what I mean? Like if you're dumb enough to answer that ad, then you might get pulled into this multi-level marketing thing. There's a stroke of evil genius to it. So Colorado didn't work out. How do you get to Maui? That's what, yeah.
我是说，它真正做的是真正的才华在于它过滤掉了那些对批判性思维者太挑剔的人，你知道我的意思吗？就像如果你笨到回答那个广告，那么你可能会被拉进这个多层次营销的东西。这有一种邪恶天才的笔触。所以科罗拉多州没成功。你怎么去毛伊岛的？那是，是啊。
So I had to give that backstory to say that my mom had to fly me home from Colorado. I had like a $1,500 cell phone bill debt. Really? And I just went back to my hometown where I had like... This is Maui. You grew up in Maui? No, no, no. I grew up in a town called Lake Steves in Washington State,
所以我不得不给出那个背景故事，说我妈妈不得不把我从科罗拉多州飞回家。我欠了大约1500美元的手机费债务。真的吗？我只是回到了我的家乡，在那里我有像... 这是毛伊岛。你在毛伊岛长大的？不，不，不。我在华盛顿州一个叫莱克史蒂夫斯的镇长大，
but a good friend of mine since high school had been living in Maui. And he saw me and he was like, dude, what happened? I heard you were like a big, big, big sales in a sales company or something. And he said, listen, man, I'm going to buy you a one-way ticket to Maui. I've been living there since high school. It's awesome. We sleep on the beach. It's super fun.
但我高中时的一个好朋友一直住在毛伊岛。他看到我，他就像，伙计，怎么了？我听说你像是一个大，大，大销售在销售公司之类的。他说，听着，伙计，我要给你买一张去毛伊岛的单程票。我从高中起就住在那儿。太棒了。我们睡在沙滩上。超级有趣。
If you like to make money, you like to fly to Maui. And so he paid for my ticket out there and then I just basically moved there. And so I had no money, but I showed up and hung out with a bunch of friends and got a job at Bubblegum Shrimp Company and lived on the beach in this sort of... People say homeless and you kind of like living in LA. There's homeless people everywhere. It's like destitute people. Just a bunch of kids living camping on the beach for a year.
如果你喜欢赚钱，你喜欢飞往毛伊岛。所以他为我的票付了钱，然后我基本上搬到了那里。所以我没有钱，但我出现了，和一群朋友在一起，在阿甘虾公司找了一份工作，住在沙滩上，在这种，就像... 人们说无家可归，你有点像住在洛杉矶。到处都是无家可归的人。就像赤贫的人。只是一群孩子在沙滩上露营了一年。
Because you could. Yeah. And then where did the acting bug and the trip to LA come from? Well, I always had that acting bug from having performed in school and having done plays. And I was doing stand-up comedy while I was doing the sales thing because that office was in Seattle. So I was performing at some open mic nights and things like that. Entry like I did a college tour thing at the University of Washington and stuff doing stand-up comedy. So I had the bug and I just, I waited on a director and the director saw me and was like,
因为你可以。是啊。然后表演虫子和去洛杉矶的旅行是从哪里来的？嗯，我一直有那个表演虫子，因为在学校表演过，做过戏。而且我在做销售工作时在做单口喜剧，因为那个办公室在西雅图。所以我会在一些开放麦之夜之类的东西上表演。进入就像我在华盛顿大学做了一个大学巡回演出之类的东西，做单口喜剧。所以我有了虫子，我只是，我等了一个导演，导演看到了我，就像，
Hey, you're cute. You act. And I was like, Yeah, I totally act. You should put me in a movie. And the audition came and I auditioned for a movie. And the movie was, you know, I got paid 700 bucks. It was shot over 10 days. It was like this when he sagged, signatory type of films.
嘿，你很可爱。你演戏吗？我就说，对啊，我完全演戏。你应该让我去拍电影。后来试镜机会来了，我去试镜了一部电影。那部电影，你知道，我拿了700美元。拍了10天。就是那种演员工会签约类型的电影。
And I remember auditioning and I worked so hard on this material. And I just remember halfway through the director said, you know what, you're pretty good. We're going to use you. And I'm like, wow, I think I'm going to get, I got this part that's great. I said, where do you, where does it film? Like, is it, is it like on this side of the island? Does the other side? I said, Oh, no, a film's in LA.
我记得当时去试镜，我为这些素材做了很多努力。我只记得演到一半时，导演说，你知道吗，你演得挺好的。我们要用你。我就想，哇，我想我能得到这个角色，太棒了。我说，你们在哪儿拍？是在岛的这一边吗？还是另一边？她说，哦，不，是在洛杉矶拍。
And in my mind, I'm like, well, I've got maybe 60 bucks to my name. I can't go to LA. Plus you've got barbecue shrimp, grilled shrimp, mustard shrimp, boiled shrimp, fried shrimp, fried shrimp, mustard shrimp, barbecue shrimp, fried shrimp, fried salad shrimp. So dumb. But you met this Hollywood Titan at a table for one at Bubba Shrimp. Shrimp. Yes.
我心里想，我身上大概只有60美元。我没法去洛杉矶。再说你还有烤虾、煎虾、芥末虾、水煮虾、炸虾、炸虾、芥末虾、烤虾、炸虾、炸虾沙拉。太蠢了。但你在阿甘虾餐厅的单人桌遇到了这位好莱坞大亨。虾。是的。
This. Okay. Yeah. The director and her producing partner were getting ready to shoot this movie. And then it was like a, you know, I auditioned and then I said, I can't, I can't go to LA. I don't have any, I don't have any money to get to LA. And she said, sweetie will fly you there. And that was it.
这个。好吧。对。导演和她的制片搭档正准备拍这部电影。然后就像，你知道，我试镜了，然后我说，我不能去洛杉矶。我没钱去洛杉矶。她说，亲爱的，我们会送你过去。就这样。
And I never, never went back. No way. Had you ever been to LA? Never. Oh, well, only time I'd been to LA was on a door to door sales road trip where I came down to sell some stuff because they had an LA office. So I, they, they had sent me down to sell in some areas. Like I sold an oxnard and I was on like up and down Santa Monica Boulevard and West Hollywood
然后我就再也没回去过。不可能。你去过洛杉矶吗？从来没去过。哦，好吧，我唯一一次去洛杉矶是在一次上门推销的公路旅行中，我下来卖点东西，因为他们在洛杉矶有办公室。所以他们派我下来在一些地区推销。比如我在奥克斯纳德推销过，还在圣莫尼卡大道和西好莱坞跑来跑去。
and stuff. But that's so interesting because I picture like you in Maui or anybody who wants to be an actor. I think the last place to find work is Maui. It is. It's so crazy. Yeah. It wasn't one of these things that I was really looking for it.
之类的。但这太有趣了，因为我脑海中想象你在茂宜岛，或者任何想当演员的人。我觉得最难找到工作的地方就是茂宜岛。确实是。太疯狂了。对。这并不是我刻意去寻找的东西。
It was, I was just, I was just having a good time with my friends and enjoying my life and had that opportunity not presented like literally shaking the tree and knocked me out of the tree and grabbed me by the hair and dragged me to LA. I don't know that I've ever, I ever would have had an opportunity to pursue what was a dream of. Yeah. It's a while. You're going door to door.
我当时只是和朋友们玩得很开心，享受生活，如果不是那个机会出现，就像真的摇晃树木把我从树上摇下来，抓住我的头发把我拖到洛杉矶。我不知道我是否还有机会去追求我曾经的梦想。对。这很有趣。你当时在挨家挨户推销。
You're talking about like Santa Monica Boulevard, just going door to door. Yeah. You're talking about business. We would always sell the people. Oh, business to business. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
你说的是像圣莫尼卡大道那样，挨家挨户地去。对。你说的是生意。我们总是向人们推销。哦，企业对企业（B2B）。对。对。对。
So B2B, but are you? It's not B2B, Will. Jason, you're not in the thing. You're not in the game with us. Sorry. In the game. We're on B2B. I'm going to correct you on the B2B stuff.
所以是B2B，但是你？这不是B2B，威尔。杰森，你没参与进来。你没和我们一起玩。抱歉。在游戏里。我们在做B2B。我要纠正你关于B2B的事情。
No, you're not in the game. That's not a phrase. No, we're going. Do you think we have time to go business to business? No. We're going B2B. What time? No.
不，你没参与。那不是一个短语。不，我们要走了。你觉得我们有时间去做企业对企业吗？不。我们要去做B2B。什么时间？不。
We're going to B2B every second. So you're going to B2B. I'm with you. But you must have crazy. Crazy encounters, were you going cold calling? Yeah, I had crazy encounters. You did? It was terrible.
我们每秒钟都在做B2B。所以你要去做B2B。我跟你一起。但你一定遇到过疯狂的事情。疯狂的遭遇，你是去冷呼叫吗？对，我遇到过疯狂的遭遇。你真的遇到了？太可怕了。
I mean, yeah, terrible. It's funny now to hear actors talk about rejection, you know? They're like, dude, it's so hard. I'm like, mother, you were invited to the place where you got rejected. I'm sneaking through people's yards and trying to climb in their windows just to talk to someone who I'm walking right past a no soliciting sign to solicit. Right. Shotgun blast could come right through that door.
我是说，对，太可怕了。现在听到演员谈论拒绝很有趣，你知道吗？他们说，伙计，这太难了。我就想，天哪，你是因为被邀请去那个地方才被拒绝的。我当时是在翻越别人的院子，试图爬进他们的窗户，只是为了和某人说话，我甚至直接无视了“禁止推销”的牌子去推销。对。霰弹枪的子弹可能直接穿过那扇门。
Well, I had people try to stick their dogs on me. I had like, I had my crew, people that I hired on my crew, you know, the elite sales force that answered them, the Ding Dong ad. The other folks that love the rock and roll and money. They would go in and rob places. Wait, really? Yeah. I had hired up in Seattle on my crew.
嗯，有人试图放狗咬我。我当时有我的团队，我雇佣的人，你知道，那些回应“叮咚”广告的精英销售团队。那些热爱摇滚和金钱的人。他们会进去抢劫。等等，真的吗？对。我在西雅图雇佣了我的团队。
I hired a guy who was like a violent felon, a convicted two time violent felon on house arrest. And we were like, hey, listen, this guy's great. We really like him. They're like, he needs to be under supervision all the time. He absolutely will be like, hey, buddy, this is your street. We'll pick him at five. No way.
我雇了一个人，他是个暴力重罪犯，被判过两次暴力重罪，处于居家监禁中。我们当时想，嘿，听着，这家伙很棒。我们真的很喜欢他。他们说，他需要一直处于监管之下。他绝对会像，嘿，伙计，这是你的街道。我们五点去接他。不可能。
That's not. No way. Yeah, for real. And that guy, Audie, his name is Audie. He was very sweet. He was actually an amazing guy and he was a really special guy. Like, it sounds way worse than it was. He actually was a really great guy who needed a break and was a really solid dude.
那不是。不可能。对，真的。那个人，奥迪，他叫奥迪。他非常可爱。他实际上是个了不起的人，他是个非常特别的人。听起来比实际情况糟糕得多。他其实是个很棒的人，只是需要一个机会，是个非常可靠的家伙。
I think he actually ended up back in prison, but he had some really crazy stories. And I was like his manager. I was 18 years old. I was 42 and he's like, and it was just the wild, it was a wild experience. Dude, dude, you kind of grew up fast in that kind of thing, don't you? You learn a lot about like, oh, avoid this. Oh, that's wrong. Oh, I should go over here, right?
我想他最后还是回到了监狱，但他有一些非常疯狂的故事。我当时是他的经理。我才18岁。他42岁，他就像，那真是一次疯狂的经历。伙计，伙计，你在那种环境下成长得很快，不是吗？你学到了很多关于，哦，避开这个。哦，那是错的。哦，我应该去这边，对吧？
It's a great preparation for being an actor. I'll tell you that. Cause like you're walking, like when you're in it, when you're, for the longest time, I was great at auditioning and I couldn't act my way out of a paper bag. Like they'd get on set and they're like, what happened to the actor who came into the thing? I was like, oh, that wasn't an actor. That was a door-to-door salesman.
这对做演员来说是很好的准备。我告诉你。因为就像你走的时候，当你身处其中时，很长一段时间里，我擅长试镜，但我根本不会演戏。就像他们到了片场，他们说，那个来试镜的演员去哪儿了？我就说，哦，那不是演员。那是挨家挨户的推销员。
I walked into a room and I won the role, but I didn't know what the F I was doing. I didn't know how to act, you know what I mean? So starting with those kinds of humble beginnings and really no huge expectations or goals or plans or obviously, you know, things are incredible now, certainly in comparison to that. But even if you had come out with a bunch of ambition and confidence and plans, it still would be incredible right now. So my question is where, where does your current ambition sit? Are you still looking at it through the perspective of the guy living on a beach in Maui?
我走进房间，赢得了角色，但我根本不知道自己在做什么。我不知道怎么演戏，你明白我的意思吗？所以从那些卑微的开始，真的没有巨大的期望、目标或计划，显然，你知道，现在一切都很不可思议，当然与那时相比。但即使你带着雄心壮志、自信和计划出来，现在的一切依然会是不可思议的。所以我的问题是，你目前的雄心在哪里？你还在用那个住在茂宜岛海滩上的家伙的视角看问题吗？
And if so, you're probably all good and ready to retire at any moment or has, have you morphed into somebody that is like, well, no, I'm just halfway done and I want to go to place X. It's inevitably, I have changed and, you know, my, my, I've grown a lot just because I grew up in a pretty small town and I've just been exposed to a lot more in my life now. So like, I'm, I'm, I'm still ambitious, but I, but I, but I see people similar in like, I guess peers of mine who are prolific actors and stars of movies and brands and icons.
如果是这样，你可能随时准备退休了，或者你已经变成了一个觉得，嗯，不，我才完成了一半，我想去X地方的人。不可避免地，我改变了，你知道，我成长了很多，因为我在一个小镇长大，现在我的人生经历丰富多了。所以，我仍然有雄心，但我看到一些和我同龄的人，他们是多产的演员，是电影明星、品牌代言人和偶像。
And I, I don't want that, I don't think I want to, I don't want to spend all of my time trying to build like an empire or something because you see some folks that are really driven in that way and that's great for them. But for me, I, I really feel like I want to work to live, you know, and yeah, I get that. You get that from you. I like anytime I see you or either in, you know, on TV or in person at a dinner that we have or whatever, I get that from you. Like you, you, your, your life is very, very full.
我不想那样，我不认为我想，我不想花所有时间去建立一个帝国之类的东西，因为你看到有些人确实很有动力，这对他们来说很好。但对我来说，我真的觉得我想为了生活而工作，你知道，是的，我明白。我从你身上感受到了。我喜欢任何时候看到你，无论是在电视上，还是在我们一起吃饭时，或者其他什么场合，我都能从你身上感受到。就像你的生活非常非常充实。
Everything is gravy, you know, um, that's the sense I can relate to the, I relate to that too. Yeah. You're good about that, Willie. What are barbecue and shrimp and boiled shrimp, creole, shrimp, this is going to be a nice stitch for the shrimp we're going to make, um, what about, um, what, tell us about the parts of your life that we might not know as much about to the extent you're comfortable. You know, you say you work to live, what, what are some of those things in your life
一切都是额外的收获，你知道，那是那种我能感同身受的感觉。我也能感同身受。对。你在这方面做得很好，威利。什么是烤虾、水煮虾、克里奥尔虾，这将是我们要做的那道虾的一道好菜，嗯，关于，嗯，告诉我们一些我们可能不太了解的你生活中的部分，在你觉得舒服的范围内。你知道，你说你为了生活而工作，你生活中有些什么事情
that work affords you the opportunity to do? And I'm speaking, obviously not about finances, but just your, your personal life, your time, family, stuff like that. Because you do work a lot. Like, you know, you're always working. It's the truth. It's, it's the truth. I have been, I have been working a lot.
是工作让你有机会去做的？我说的显然不是财务方面，而是你的个人生活、时间、家庭之类的。因为你确实工作很多。就像，你知道，你总是忙于工作。这是事实。这是事实。我一直在忙于工作。
I mean, uh, I love, I, I have a farm. I'm really passionate about a farm. I have a ranch and I up in, uh, I've been Washington state and we raise animals and, um, and that's, uh, a big passion of mine. Um, what's your favorite thing to do on the farm? Just to be there, just to, just to be there and to be kind of like, shoot movies, Mads of Uses. Shoot movies.
我是说，我爱，我有一个农场。我对农场充满热情。我有一个牧场，我在华盛顿州，我们饲养动物，那是我的一个大爱好。嗯，你在农场最喜欢做什么？只是待在那里，只是待在那里，就像拍电影，马兹·尤塞斯。拍电影。
Yeah. Yeah. I'm doing a reality. I'm doing a reality. Um, but like, do you like, is there a tractor you like to drive? Are you like ride horses? Do you milk cows? We don't have horses.
对。对。我正在做真人秀。我正在做真人秀。嗯，但是你喜欢，有没有你喜欢开的拖拉机？你喜欢骑马吗？你挤牛奶吗？我们没有马。
We have, uh, goats and sheep. I have a, I have a, there's a lake there. I love to fish. I'm a huge bass fisherman. So. Oh yeah. They say that you're, you know, if you want to know where you're, uh, how you're fishing, the heart is, where does your mind go when it wanders?
我们有山羊和绵羊。我有一个，那里有个湖。我喜欢钓鱼。我是个超级鲈鱼钓手。所以。哦，是的。他们说，你知道，如果你想知道你的钓鱼技术如何，心在哪里，当你的思绪游离时，它会去哪里？
And for me, I'm just on, I'm, my eyes are closed and I'm just fishing this lake. And I like, it to me, it's like a, it's a 22 acre lake and it's like an aquarium to me. I like, I've put in all these fish and I removed weeds and I'm constantly in the mind thinking about this lake and, and the tight, we just put a new type of, uh, hybrid bass in there called a wiper, which is like a white fishing striper hybrid, which is really extraordinary fish. So obviously you're catching these fish and releasing them back in.
对我来说，我只是，我闭上眼睛，我正在那个湖里钓鱼。对我来说，那是一个22英亩的湖，就像一个水族馆。我放了这些鱼，清除了杂草，我一直在思考这个湖，还有，我们刚刚放了一种新型的杂交鲈鱼，叫“雨刷鱼”，它是白鲈和条纹鲈的杂交品种，是非常非凡的鱼。所以显然你钓到这些鱼后又把它们放回去了。
Yeah. Catch and release fish. And I'm going up there for this summer with, uh, after, uh, we have a baby that's doing after the baby's born. I'm taking my nine year old son, Jack, and we're going to go up there and camp for 10 days. It's literally. That's so cool.
对。钓后放。今年夏天我要去那里，在孩子出生后。我要带我九岁的儿子杰克去那里露营10天。这简直是。太酷了。
It dominates a huge portion of my mind when I'm like, when it's wandering, I'm just, I'm just fishing with Jack up there. And I'm going to show them these 10 movies. I've got like 10 days, 10 movies, and it's going to be like the coming of age summer like, what kind of movies? Yeah. What's on the list? I got the list.
当我思绪游离时，它占据了我大脑的很大一部分，我只是在和杰克在那里钓鱼。我要给他看这10部电影。我有10天时间，10部电影，这将是一个成长的夏天，什么样的电影？对。清单上有什么？我有清单。
I mean, they're pretty funny movies. Oh, I'll tell you right now. Imagine if there were all Jason Bateman movies that would be so weird off his Christmas party. On my movies. I did your own movies. Don't you get, you're doing it wrong. Um, I got, okay.
我是说，它们是相当有趣的电影。哦，我现在就告诉你。想象一下，如果全是杰森·贝特曼的电影，那会很奇怪，比如《圣诞派对》。我的电影。我拍了你自己的电影。你做错了吧。嗯，我有，好吧。
Rambo first blood. Sure. Sure. Oh, by the way, that's from that area. This is just you and Jack. We're going to watch these. Yes. Okay.
《第一滴血》。当然。当然。哦，顺便说一下，那是那个地区的。这只是你和杰克。我们要看这些。是的。好吧。
Great. Uh, Dumb and Dumber. Yep. White Fang. Okay. White Fang. It's like, I think it's based on a Jack London book and I think it may have Ethan Hawke when he was younger.
太棒了。嗯，《阿呆与阿瓜》。对。《白牙》。好吧。《白牙》。我想它是基于杰克·伦敦的书，我想可能还有年轻时的伊桑·霍克。
Yeah. Sure, sure. Yeah. Peabee's Big Adventure. Yes. Oh, yeah. Rudy. Oh, gosh, yeah.
对，当然。对。《皮威大冒险》。是的。哦，是的。《鲁迪》。哦，天哪，是的。
Toy Soldiers. What's that? Oh, yeah. It's like Sean Aston and when they were very young and they like go, their school gets taken over by terrorists and they go crazy and like kill terrorists. Like a Red Dawn type of thing. Yeah. It's like that.
《玩具兵团》。那是什么？哦，是的。就像肖恩·奥斯汀他们很小的时候，他们的学校被恐怖分子占领了，他们变得疯狂，杀死了恐怖分子。就像《赤色黎明》那种类型。对。就像那样。
Uh, Red Dawn. Is Red Dawn on the list? Yeah, it's on the list. What about Taps? You got Taps on there? Taps, that's great. I'm adding it to the list. Come on, Chris.
嗯，《赤色黎明》。《赤色黎明》在清单上吗？对，在清单上。那《熄灯号》呢？你有《熄灯号》吗？《熄灯号》，那太棒了。我把它加到清单里。来吧，克里斯。
And then we've got Bloodsport and Crouchy Tiger Hidden Dragon and Monty Python and the Holy Grail. Those are the ones on the list. Yes. And we will be right back. All right. Back to the show. I, I, um, um, I was thinking about, um, I really just drifted off there.
然后我们有《血点》、《卧虎藏龙》和《巨蟒与圣杯》。这些就是清单上的。是的。我们马上回来。好的。回到节目。我，我，嗯，嗯，我在想，嗯，我刚才真的走神了。
Oh, granddad. I can pick it up for you. Just lay down. Lay down. Just pull the microphone down to the floor. There are some cool things that, there's some cool things that Chris, I didn't know, uh, until I read this about you. First of all, I think it's always fascinating for people to hear when you, uh, you audition
哦，爷爷。我可以帮你接上。躺下。躺下。把麦克风拉到地板上。有一些很酷的事情，有一些克里斯很酷的事情，我不知道，直到我读到关于你的这些。首先，我觉得人们听到你试镜时总是很着迷
for something you didn't get or whatever. We all have our stories, but I didn't know you auditioned for Captain Kirk and the lead in Avatar, both movies. Jesus, you get great auditions. And did you come close to getting them? No, I didn't come close. In fact, it was a real, uh, I know I've, I've, you know, made light of actors feeling rejection or whatever, but I didn't come close.
对于你没得到的角色或者其他什么。我们都有自己的故事，但我不知道你试镜过《星际迷航》的柯克船长和《阿凡达》的主角，两部电影。天哪，你试镜的机会真好。你离得到这些角色很近吗？不，我一点也不近。事实上，这是一个真正的，嗯，我知道我曾经轻描淡写过演员感受到的拒绝之类的，但我一点也不近。
In fact, I came, it was so not close that I, it was really demoralizing and made me actually truly question my potential or, or what I, or what I should be aiming for as an actor, you know. For which one? For both of those? For both of those. I remember that the role was written like he comes in, it was like maybe the avatar. Were you reading for one of the avatars?
事实上，我离得太远了，以至于这真的很令人沮丧，让我真正质疑我的潜力，或者我作为一名演员应该追求什么，你知道。是哪一个？两个都吗？两个都。我记得那个角色写的是他走进来，就像可能是《阿凡达》。你在读《阿凡达》里的一个角色吗？
I was reading to place the role in Avatar is one of them and then another one I was reading for Captain Kirk. And then another one I was reading for something that JJ Abrams did, Star Trek, maybe Star Trek. That maybe that was the Captain Kirk, but anyways, I just remember reading that this character description was like, he walks in and he has the it factor. Oh boy. It is just the it factor.
我当时在读《阿凡达》里的一个角色，另一个我在读柯克船长。还有一个我在读JJ·艾布拉姆斯做的东西，可能是《星际迷航》。可能那是柯克船长，但无论如何，我只记得读到那个角色描述时，就像他走进来，他有那种“特质”。哦，天哪。就是那种“特质”。
It is guy, you know. And so I was like feeling a little like maybe overweight. I hadn't been taking great care of myself physically. I was like in a relationship where we were kind of drinking a lot and I was just sort of like, you know, I walked in and I, I started sweating immediately and it was a casting assistant and she just looked at me and she just looked down and she just pressed record and like started doing her stuff while I was reading with the other casting assistant. And I saw that there was literally nothing about my, my audition that was compelling
就是那个家伙，你知道。所以我感觉有点像超重了。我在身体上没有好好照顾自己。我当时处于一段我们喝了很多酒的关系中，我只是觉得，你知道，我走进去，我立刻开始出汗，那是一个选角助理，她只是看着我，然后低下头，按下录音键，在我和其他选角助理对戏时开始做她的事。我看到我的试镜中确实没有任何东西在吸引她
her whatsoever. It was like, it was like, fuck, this is, what am I doing? And I had enough of those in that stretch of a very lean stretch in my career, by the way, that I didn't get hired for a couple of years. It was shortly before parks and rack. And, and then that's when I kind of, I just regaged like, because early on in my early in my twenties, I wasn't, I was in pretty good shape. I was, I was working out a lot.
任何一点。就像，就像，该死，这是，我在做什么？在那段我职业生涯非常清淡的时期，我有过很多次这样的经历，顺便说一下，我好几年没被雇佣。那是在《公园与游憩》之前不久。然后那时我重新调整了，因为在二十出头的时候，我身材还不错。我经常锻炼。
I was training. I was young and, and I felt like potentially I could, you know, I was mostly getting those roles. The auditions for like douchebag boyfriend, you know, they gotta be like, Hey, my dad's got his escalator so I did the bitch or whatever the line was, you know, it's been two weeks figuring out how to do that line. I never got any, I never read for any douchebag parts. Interesting.
我在训练。我很年轻，我觉得我可能，你知道，我大多得到的是那些角色。试镜像“混蛋男友”，你知道，他们得像，嘿，我爸有他的自动扶梯，所以我做了那个婊子或者无论那句台词是什么，你知道，花了两个星期弄清楚怎么说那句台词。我从来没读过任何混蛋角色。有趣。
Really? Yeah. It's weird. That is so surprising to me. I know. I know. Really, there's really, really surprising. I've actually never seen anybody more surprised at something than you at that statement.
真的吗？对。很奇怪。这让我感到非常惊讶。我知道。我知道。真的，真的非常令人惊讶。我其实从来没见过比你听到那句话时更惊讶的人。
So anyways, yeah. So I auditioned for those things and I knew in the moment that I, first of all, I wasn't prepared. Like I hadn't done the work that I needed to do physically to be the guy who walks into the room and kind of commands attention. Like, yeah. And so that was when I kind of got Andy and I was like, wait a minute, there's something a little bit maybe more compelling about a clown, you know, that I could play.
所以无论如何，是的。所以我试镜了那些东西，我当时就知道，首先，我没准备好。就像我没有在身体上做我需要做的工作，成为那个走进房间并能掌控注意力的人。就像，对。所以那时我得到了安迪，我就想，等一下，小丑身上可能有一些更吸引人的东西，你知道，我可以演。
I can put this clown, I remember for the first season, I noticed I was self-conscious, like I feel like I'm getting a little chunky. And then I saw the stuff I was doing, I was like, this is actually really funny. And so I told Mike Schur. I was like, I'm going to gain a bunch of weight this summer. He's like, all right, dude. Sounds good. Mike Schur is a showrunner.
我可以扮演这个小丑，我记得第一季，我注意到我很自觉，就像我觉得我有点变胖了。然后我看到了我做的事情，我就想，这其实真的很有趣。所以我告诉迈克·舒尔。我说，我今年夏天要增重很多。他说，好吧，伙计。听起来不错。迈克·舒尔是剧集主管。
Yeah. Mike Schur is a showrunner. And so Andy kind of got fatter and fatter as the seasons went on. By the way, shout out to Mike Schur. Real quick. Yeah. Mike Schur is one of the, one of the all time funniest guys and we knew him back when he was, he used to be a head writer of update and we remember Jayce, we remember how close
对。迈克·舒尔是剧集主管。所以安迪随着季节的推移变得越来越胖。顺便说一下，向迈克·舒尔致敬。很快。对。迈克·舒尔是有史以来最有趣的人之一，我们认识他的时候，他还是《周六夜现场》更新板块的首席编剧，我们记得杰斯，我们记得我们有多接近
we came to that one May where we almost got him to come and write on the second season of Arrested Development. And then he was stolen by Greg Daniels and it was just, there was a moment, he was like, is it going to happen? You're so known. I don't want to blame it on Mitch, but it was Mitch Horwich's fault that he didn't. But thank God, but thank God, because then he went on to the office and then he went on, did Parks and Rec and then he did, you know, The Good Place and Brooklyn Nine-Nine
在那一年的五月，我们差点让他来写《发展受阻》第二季。然后他被格雷格·丹尼尔斯偷走了，当时有一个时刻，他就像，会发生吗？你太出名了。我不想怪米奇，但没成是米奇·霍维奇的错。但谢天谢地，因为后来他去了《办公室》，然后他做了《公园与游憩》，然后他做了，你知道，《善地》和《神烦警探》
and all these other great shows with the great game work. Chris, did anybody ever tell, like, I always thought you could be the next Indiana Jones. Did anybody approach you about that? Like why aren't you doing that? Come on, Chris. Well, a lot of what Colin Travarro did with the Owen character that I play in. He's the, Colin's the director of Jurassic World. He's the director of Jurassic World.
以及所有这些伟大的节目，有着伟大的游戏工作。克里斯，有没有人说过，我一直觉得你可以成为下一个印第安纳·琼斯。有人找过你吗？为什么你不做那个？来吧，克里斯。嗯，科林·特雷沃罗在我扮演的欧文角色中做了很多。他是《侏罗纪世界》的导演。他是《侏罗纪世界》的导演。
And but the Owen character that he like created that he did with me, he bought, a lot of that, you know, obviously, Steven Spielberg did Jurassic Park and so Colin was like creating this ode to the work that Steven had done. And I think borrows a lot of, a lot of, you know, the physicality of like Indiana Jones. And I think that's likely why. And the humor, yeah. Like, you know, like with vests and the humors and the one-liners and the kind of like, even the dynamic between my relationship between my character and Bryce Dallas Howard's character
但是科林创造的那个欧文角色，他和我一起做的，他买了很多，你知道，显然，史蒂文·斯皮尔伯格拍了《侏罗纪公园》，所以科林就像在创作一首对史蒂文所做工作的颂歌。我认为借用了很多，你知道，像印第安纳·琼斯那样的身体素质。我想这很可能是原因。还有幽默感，对。就像，你知道，背心和幽默感，还有俏皮话，甚至是我角色和布莱丝·达拉斯·霍华德角色之间的那种动态
in the first Jurassic World, it feels a little similar to some of that stuff. So it was kind of an ode in a way to Indiana Jones. So what's the guy Colin like? Is he a nice guy? American guy? Yeah, American guy. Great guy. Really nice guy, super talented and just incredibly dedicated.
在第一部《侏罗纪世界》里，感觉有点像那些东西。所以这在某种程度上是对印第安纳·琼斯的颂歌。那么科林是个什么样的人？他是个好人吗？美国人？对，美国人。很棒的人。非常好的人，超级有才华，而且极其敬业。
I mean, you want, I watch him work in that part of me, the small little flame in the back of my mind is like, you know, maybe I ought to direct is like, oh, I can't, I couldn't do that. I could no way I could do what he does. He's got, he's so thoughtful as a special skill. He's listens to every single person, truly takes in their input, considers it, you know, make sure that everyone feels really good. He has that perfect ability to, you know, not meddle with somebody because actors are
我是说，你想要，我看着他工作，我脑海深处那点小火苗就像，你知道，也许我应该导演，就像，哦，我不能，我做不到。我绝对做不到他所做的事情。他有，他非常有思想，是一种特殊技能。他听取每一个人的意见，真正吸收他们的输入，考虑它，你知道，确保每个人都感觉很好。他有那种完美的能力，你知道，不去干涉某人，因为演员们
all so different and each so sensitive. You have to actually have a separate skill set of like understanding which technique you're going to use to get what you need from somebody. I was going to say, so Chris, that's why I was asking, is these directors who do that and the ones who are really successful have that ability to take, to wear so many different hats, to listen to so many people, to really collaborate, and it always makes me, when I see them do that and be so good, I always think like, how the fuck does Bateman direct? That's a really strict.
都太不同了，每个人都太敏感了。你实际上必须拥有一种单独的技能，了解你将使用哪种技术来从某人那里得到你需要的东西。我正想说，所以克里斯，这就是我问的原因，这些这样做的导演，以及那些真正成功的导演，都有那种能力去承担，去戴上许多不同的帽子，去听取许多人的意见，去真正合作，这总是让我，当我看到他们这样做并且做得这么好时，我总是想，贝特曼到底是怎么导演的？那真是太严格了。
You know what I mean? Because he doesn't possess any of that shit. He's not listening to anybody. Always a lot of time. All he's thinking about, how the fuck can I get out of there and why the fuck are you talking to me? What's the look on his face? I'm trying to shorten the question.
你知道我的意思吗？因为他根本不具备那些东西。他根本不听任何人的。总是很多时间。他想的只是，我他妈怎么才能从这里出去，你他妈为什么要跟我说话？他脸上的表情是什么？我正试图缩短问题。
Who the fuck told you to step to me? I'm trying to get the fuck out of here. Oh, you're crazy. Hey, unless you're telling me to tell, coming to tell me that my Tesla is fully charged, I don't want to fucking hear from you. Hey, Chris, before we let you go, I wanted you to tell me a little bit about what we were doing on the show. I want you to tell me about the terminal list, because it's a show coming out on Amazon
谁他妈让你靠近我的？我正试图他妈的从这里出去。哦，你疯了。嘿，除非你是来告诉我，来告诉我我的特斯拉已经充满电了，否则我他妈不想听你说。嘿，克里斯，在你走之前，我想让你告诉我一点我们在节目中做的事情。我想让你告诉我关于《终极名单》，因为它是一部即将在亚马逊上线的节目
that you're starting. Oh my God, you have 85,000 things going on. What is the terminal list about? I'm sure I'm on it. I'm so pumped about it. Can we guess what it's about? Okay. I thought I saw a promo for you where I go, is Pat doing a fucking show, like a limited
你主演的。哦，天哪，你有85000件事在进行。什么是《终极名单》？我肯定我在上面。我对此非常兴奋。我们可以猜猜它是关于什么的吗？好吧。我以为我看到了你的宣传片，我当时想，帕特是在拍一部他妈的剧，比如限定剧还是什么鬼？所以我们在机场。而你是负责那个的人，所以是候补名单，那些办理登机手续太晚的人，他们可以被列入候补名单。所以你是航站楼里拿着名单的家伙，让人们的飞行梦想成真。这足以说明杰森坐商业航班是多久以前的事了。对。是那样运作的吗？
series or some shit? So we're in an airport. And you are the person who's in charge of the, so it's the standby, the people who have checked in too late and they could put on a standby list. So you are the guy in the terminal with the list, making people's playing dreams come true. This goes to show you how long ago it was that Jason flew commercial. Yeah. Is that the way it works?
听起来是个很棒的角色。我告诉你，不是那样的。我能看出为什么亚马逊会拒绝那个想法，但好吧，别偷我的想法。那是什么？所以它是基于一位名叫杰克·卡尔的作者的《纽约时报》畅销小说。杰克·卡尔是一位前海豹突击队队员，我的哥们杰瑞德，当我拍一部叫《猎杀本·拉登》的电影时。肯定拍过。
It sounds like a great part. I'm going to tell you what, it's not that. I could see why Amazon would pass on that idea, but okay, don't steal my idea. What is it? So it's based on a New York Times bestselling novel by an author named Jack Carr. Jack Carr is a former Navy SEAL and my buddy Jared, when I did a film called Zero Dark Thirty. Sure you did.
太棒了。那部电影不错。那是一部好电影。而且，你知道，我扮演海豹突击队第六分队的成员，在做那个的过程中，我有机会去科罗纳多，见到那里的海豹突击队员，见到一些正在训练BUDS项目的训练人员。那是他们在南加州的训练中心，对吧？对。
Fantastic. Not a bad film there. That was a good one. And, you know, I play SEAL team six member and in the process of doing that, I got to go down to Coronado and meet the SEALs down there and meet some trained guys who were training the BUDS program down there. That's their training center in Southern California, right? Yeah, right.
那是BUDS训练项目。就像，你知道，每个人都看到在海滩上扛圆木，所有那些艰难的海豹突击队训练都是在科罗纳多的那里完成的。你不需要告诉我，伙计。对。不需要告诉我。继续，告诉其他人。所以我见到了那里的一位家伙，我最终为我扮演的角色对他进行了跟踪观察
That's the BUDS training program. It's like, you know, everyone sees the carrying the logs on the beach and all that tough Navy SEAL training is done down there in Coronado. You don't need to tell me, dude. Yep. I don't need to tell me that. Keep going, tell everybody else. And so I met a guy down there who I ended up kind of shadowing for the character that
直到今天，他现在就像我最好的朋友。哦，那太棒了。他非常可靠，很棒的人。我们一起工作过。他当时正在考虑加入第六分队，但也一直有做演员和在好莱坞发展的呼唤。所以就像我们的道路交叉了，我们真的有很多共同点。我们都是渔民，我们都喜欢狩猎和户外活动，我真的非常喜欢
I was playing and he to this day is now like my best friend. Oh, that's great. He's a solid as they come, awesome guy. And we've worked together. He was considering going on to team six at that point, but also had always really had a calling to do acting and to be in Hollywood. And so like our paths crossed, we just really had a lot in common. We're both fishermen, we have both like the hunt and get outdoors and I just really love
这个家伙，你知道，就像他一样可靠，真的是我最好的朋友之一。所以他认识杰克，他读了这本书，他说，嘿，看看这本书。我朋友写的这本书。你可能想把它拍成电影。所以我读了这本书，我得到了，我购买了这本书的版权，同时，安托万·福奎阿，导演安托万·福奎阿，他导演了《训练日》。他导演了我和丹泽尔·华盛顿主演的电影《豪勇七蛟龙》。安托万就像，我听说安托万也在关注这本书，试图得到
this guy, you know, just as solid as they come, truly one of my very best friends. And so he knows Jack and he read this book and he goes, hey, check out this book. My friend wrote this book. You might want to make it a movie. And so I read the book and I got, I optioned the book and at the same time, Antoine Foucault, the director Antoine Foucault, he directed Training Day. He directed me in this film, The Magnificent Seven with Denzel Washington. And Antoine was like, I heard that Antoine was also circling this book trying to get
它的版权。我就想，嘿，我只是私下给他打了电话。我说，伙计，与其我们在这本书上互相竞价，不如让我拿到版权，然后让你来导演。他说，太棒了。所以我们那样做了。然后读的时候，意识到它可能更适合做限定剧，因为这是一个关于一个家伙的故事，你知道，书本身是一部政治惊悚片，
the rights to it. And I was like, hey, I just called them on the side. I was like, dude, instead of us bidding against each other on this book, let me get the rights and I'll just have you direct it. And he said, fantastic. So we did that. And then in reading it, realized that it was probably better suited for a limited series because it's the story of a guy who, you know, the book itself is like a political thriller,
但我们把它拍成了更多心理惊悚片，带有阴谋元素。所以它在某些时刻感觉有点像《雅各布的梯子》，有这种复仇阴谋惊悚片，也有这种心理惊悚片的方面。它在亚马逊Prime上有八集。它将于7月1日上线。太棒了。我为它感到骄傲。它绝对和我做过的任何事情都不同。
but we made it more of a psychological thriller with a conspiracy element. And so it's like a little bit feels at moments like Jacob's Ladder and has this sort of revenge conspiracy thriller, also this psychological thriller aspect to it. And it's eight episodes on Amazon Prime. It's going to come out July 1st. It's fantastic. I'm so proud of it. It's definitely different than anything I've ever done.
我对此非常兴奋。它就像很硬核。我们雇佣了我的朋友杰瑞德，他是制片人，给了我这本书，是它的制片人，并在其中扮演了一个角色。我们雇佣了许多在镜头前和镜头后的人，他们都是前海豹突击队员和特种作战人员。所以，我们真的在钉住真实性。你这样做太棒了。
I'm really pumped about it. It's like gnarly. And we hired my friend Jared, who was a producer, got me the book, was a producer on it and plays a role in it. And we hired a whole bunch of people both in front of the camera and behind the camera who were former SEALs and spec ops. So like, we're really nailing down the authenticity of the. That's awesome that you do that.
我喜欢那个。你知道我还喜欢什么吗？我最近听到你谈论，就像你总是包容的。你总是试图让每个人，你知道，聚在一起。我喜欢它。你能从你身上感觉到，你让某个家伙在《侏罗纪公园》里，就像先被吃掉。那是什么故事？关于一些，你有一个比赛，你甚至没问制片厂。
I love that. You know what I also love? I heard you recently talk about, like you're always inclusive. You're always trying to get everybody, you know, together. I love it. You can feel that from you and you got some guy to be in Jurassic Park, like eating first. Like, what was that story? Something about like some, you had a contest, you didn't even ask the studio.
你就像，嘿，对吧？类似那样。嗯，是的，这个，你知道，我们，我们拍了《侏罗纪世界3》。我们在疫情袭击美国时的二月开始拍摄。所以是的，你们是第一批，对吧？你们当时在英国吗？对，我们是，我们是第一批。我们被关闭了几个月，当时他们正在制定代码协议和
You're like, Hey, right? Something like that. Well, yeah, this, you know, we, we shot Jurassic World Dominion. We started filming in January when the pandemic hit the States in February. So yeah, you guys were first, right? Weren't you over in England? Yeah, we were, we were first. We got shut down for a few months while they were sort of developing code protocols and
无论是什么，都在躲藏，弄清楚，你知道，两周拉平曲线，或者当时无论是什么。我们回去工作了，你知道，我们出色的制片人。还有环球影业，彼得·克莱默，他，你们起草了所有那种复工协议。那是，那是我们的哥们弗兰克吗？那是我们的哥们弗兰克·马歇尔吗？对。
whatever was hunkered down, figuring out, you know, two weeks to flatten the curve or whatever it was at the time. And we went back to work and, you know, our amazing producers on. And Universal, Peter Kramer was, he, you guys drafted up all the sort of back to work protocols for that. Was that, was that our buddy Frank? Was that our buddy Frank Marshall? Yeah.
弗兰克，帕特·克劳利是，对，弗兰克加入了，但帕特·克劳利和亚历克斯·德比郡就像，我是说，我真的无法想象任何人怎么能处理那份工作，更不用说处理得那么好，但是的，他们想出了所有这些协议，我是说，如果有什么行业能够承担在疫情中继续前进，那真的是我们的行业。我认为电影和电视行业，就像我们做疯狂的事情。我们爬他妈的山。我们建造，建造，就像我们做不可思议的事情。
Frank, Pat Crowley was, yeah, Frank's was on board, but Pat Crowley and Alex Derbyshire were like, I mean, I literally can't imagine how anybody could handle that job, let alone as well as they did, but yeah, they came up with all these protocols and I mean, if there's any industry that's going to be able to take on proceeding through, through the global pandemic, it really is our industry. I think the film and television industry, like we do insane shit. We climb fucking mountains. We build, build, like we do incredible shit.
这就是这种，这种高度警惕的指挥链。我们刚刚创建了一个完整的，你知道，部门。这是COVID部门。所以每个人都在接受测试。每个人都在做接触者追踪。对。所有这些协议，人们站在哪里，口罩和防护罩，所有这些东西，人们在，你知道，执行规则，这对任何人来说都是一份糟糕的工作
And it's this sort of, this really hyper vigilant chain of command. We just created a whole, you know, department. It's the COVID department. So everyone's getting tested. Everyone's doing contact tracing. Yeah. All these protocols where people are going to stand and the masks and the shields and all this stuff and people are, you know, enforcing the rules, which was a terrible job for anyone
不得不做，就像，嘿，你们没有保持六英尺距离。顺便说一下，那变得很老套，听起来像是一个为你岳父做的电影的好标题。我们应该选接触者追踪。哦，天哪。在我们要谈这个之前，那听起来不像是一部好的模型电影吗？我不会。听着，你把他放在一个有候补名单的机场，没有人会去他妈的机场
to have to do to be like, Hey, you're not six feet apart. Like that gets really old by the way, that sounds like a great title of a movie for your father-in-law to do. We should pick contact tracing. Oh my God. Doesn't that sound like a good model movie before we get down to this? I will not. Listen, you put him in an airport with a standby list and nobody's going to the fucking airport
带着候补名单。候补名单不是，我不想说，但他们是对的，它不会是。它在海外播放。你被踢出名单了。我他妈的，但我很想看那个。我喜欢那个家伙。但你，但你，你有一个虚假的比赛还是什么。对。
with the standby list. The standby list is not, I hate to say it, but they're right, it's not going to be. It plays overseas. You're off the list. I fucking, but I'd love to watch that. I love that guy. But you got, but you, you had, you had this fake contest or something. Yeah.
我们有一个虚假的比赛。所以，你知道，当时我们正试图为“喂养美国”筹集资金。有一个叫“全入挑战”的东西，一大群人贡献了各种拍卖品。它筹集了6000万美元左右，5900万美元。我们的比赛项目是我们筹集的，是一个在《侏罗纪世界》中被恐龙吃掉的机会。所以每个人都花了10美元参加，你有机会参加，这个叫泰瑞的家伙
We had a fake contest. So, you know, at the time we were trying to raise money for Feeding America. There's this thing called the all in challenge and a whole bunch of people contributed various auction items. It raised $60 million or something like that, $59 million. And our contest item that we raised was an opportunity to be eaten by a dinosaur in Jurassic World. And so everyone entered for 10 bucks, you'd get a chance to enter in this dude named Terry
来自密苏里州的汤普森，在我们的电影中有一个惊人的死亡场景。他赢得了比赛，我们用绿幕拍了他。太酷了。所以让我问你关于那个。作为一个那些电影的粉丝，当一个人被恐龙抓住，像那个经典的片段一样被从地上撕起来咀嚼，是否有任何部分是人，我想象赢得这个比赛的人被挂在吊带上，被抓到空中，然后它在某种程度上变成了数字
Thompson from Missouri is, has an amazing death scene in our film. He won the contest and we shot him a green screen. It's so cool. So let me ask you about that. Just as a fan of that, of those movies, when a guy gets snatched up by a dinosaur, pulled out like that classic bit where ripped up off the ground and chew, is, is any portion of that where the person, I'm imagining the person that won this contest got hooked up to a harness and gets snatched up in the air and then they kind of, it becomes digital
那通常是你要做的事情。对。通常你会做一些像全套吊带的事情，让特技索具团队把人拉起来。大多数时候它会是一个训练有素的特技演员。所以我认为我不确定他们对泰瑞做了什么，因为他在密苏里州，我们在伦敦，他们甚至不能飞我们自己的
at some point. That's typically what you'll do. Yeah. Typically you're going to do something like a full like harness and have a stunt rigging crew pull a person up. Most of the time it's going to be a trained stuntman. So I think I'm not exactly sure what they did with Terry because he was in Missouri and we were in London and they weren't going to, we literally couldn't even fly our own
家庭成员去那里。所以他们设置了整个绿幕，做了整件事，他在密苏里州。在密苏里州。我想他们用绿幕拍他骑滑板车，然后可能做了所有事情，可能对他做了扫描，像那种身体扫描，然后做了其他所有事情。让人们参与进来并带入粉丝，带入你和肖恩和斯科蒂，你们做的那件事，你们让人们从比赛中出来，他们过来吃一盘
family members out there. So they set it up the whole green screen and did the whole thing where he was in Missouri. In Missouri. I think they shot him on a green screen just riding a scooter and then maybe did everything and maybe did a scan on him, like one of those body scans and then did everything else. So cool to get, I'm not sure that they put him through the stunt stuff to get people involved and to bring fans in and kind of bring them into what you and Sean and Scotty, you guys did that thing where you got people out of the contest and they come over and eat a plate
玉米片和你和斯科蒂一起，谁能数出袋子里有多少玉米片，然后把它们全吃掉。对。就在肖恩的沙发上吃完一袋玉米片。那天是什么运动？最大的误导是无论谁能猜出袋子里有多少玉米片，他们就能吃掉它们。但误导是每个人最后都得到了一盒。
of bugles with you and Scotty and who can count how many bugles in the bag and then eat them all. Right. Just work your way through a bag of bugles on Sean's couch. What was the day movement? The big mislead was whoever can guess as many, how many bugles are in the bag, they get to eat them. But the mislead was everybody got a box at the end anyway.
当然。这削减了利润，因为你们只筹集了，我想几百美元。居民。对。我们用它们买了更多的玉米片。吃完一袋玉米片。克里斯·帕拉特，听着，这是一种荣幸。
Sure. Which cut into the profits because you guys only raised what a couple hundred dollars I think. Resident. Yeah. We bought more bugles with them. Work your way through a bag of bugles. Chris Pratt, listen, it has been a pleasure.
谢谢你来到这里。谢谢你浪费时间陪我们。抱歉，克里斯·帕拉特。你是最棒的。这真是太荣幸了，你们。我是你们播客的超级粉丝。我喜欢你们正在做的事情。
Thank you for being here. Thank you for wasting your time with us. Sorry, Chris. Pratt. You're the best. This is such a pleasure, you guys. I'm a huge fan of you guys' podcast. I love what you're doing.
你们都太有趣了。我们会在高尔夫球场上回报你。嘿，听着，我还想说，你凭借你所做的一切，包括《侏罗纪世界3》和现在你在亚马逊上的新剧，你已经赢得了和杰克在一起的10天。听到你们要那样做，我太兴奋了。关于农场。玩得开心。
You're all so funny. We'll pay it back to you on the golf course. Hey, listen, I also want to say you have earned with all the stuff you've done with the Jurassic World Dominion and now your new series on Amazon, you have earned your 10 days with Jack. I'm so psyched to hear that you guys are going to do that. About the farm. Have the best time.
我想什么时候去那里。听起来太棒了。我喜欢它。你会喜欢的。随时。我很乐意让你们过来。随时。还有……
I want to come up there sometime. That sounds awesome. I love it. You would love it. Anytime. I would love to have you guys up. Anytime. And also...
我什么时候想上去看看。听起来太棒了。我很喜欢。你会喜欢的。随时欢迎。我很乐意邀请你们上去。随时都可以。还有...
Yeah, dude. We know we're back. We're back golfing. Chris, thank you. Thanks, Chris. Thank you very much, buddy. It's a pleasure to be here. Keep up to good work.
没错，伙计。我们知道我们回来了。我们又开始打高尔夫了。克里斯，谢谢你。谢谢，克里斯。非常感谢你，老兄。很高兴能来到这里。继续保持出色的工作。
See you down the road. Great to have you. Bye, pal. Sean, what happens to those bugles? Do they send it to you? Is it their idea? Or you guys... Did you just reach out to a sponsor?
回头见。很高兴你能来。再见，伙计。肖恩，那些Bugles零食是怎么回事？是他们寄给你的吗？是他们的主意吗？还是你们……你们只是主动联系了赞助商？
Any sort of chip? Well... It's Cheetos. Chex Mix? Chex Mix? People at Chex Mix never listen. Come back to you. That's what I was trying to say.
是某种薯片吗？嗯……是奇多（Cheetos）。Chex Mix？Chex Mix？Chex Mix的人从来不听。回到你身上。这就是我想说的。
Oh, boy. The gang at Chex Mix. But your heart was in the right place. Yeah. Listen, we... Let's do... Sorry, go ahead, Sean. No, no, that's it.
天哪。Chex Mix的那帮人。但你的心意是好的。是的。听着，我们……让我们做……抱歉，你继续，肖恩。不，不，就是这样。
Go ahead. I was going to say that, you know, if anybody's out there from bugles or Chex Mix or Cheez-Its... Cheez-Its. That's what I was thinking of. Cheez-Its. And if you want to have... I actually love Cheez-Its. We do have ourselves.
你继续。我本来想说，你知道，如果Bugles、Chex Mix或Cheez-Its的人在听……Cheez-Its。我刚才想的就是这个。Cheez-Its。如果你想……我其实很喜欢Cheez-Its。我们确实有。
We can do like a taste test or something like that because these are the things that people really want to talk about. I love Cheez-Its. I love it. I like that. Let's get back to the incredibly unpleasant, nasty Chris Pratt. Just negative. I know.
我们可以做个口味测试之类的，因为这些才是人们真正想谈论的事情。我爱Cheez-Its。我爱死它了。我喜欢这个主意。让我们回到那个极其令人不快、讨厌的克里斯·帕拉特身上。真是太消极了。我知道。
Just... Oh. I mean, how do we get through that? He's so... My God. So naturally funny. You know what's so funny? When he kind of hit with Jurassic World and Guardians of the Galaxy and he became this huge, you
只是……哦。我是说，我们怎么熬过那段？他太……天哪。太自然地搞笑了。你知道什么很有趣吗？当他凭借《侏罗纪世界》和《银河护卫队》走红，成为这个巨大的，你
know, international star, you go, you look at him and you go, yeah, what took Hollywood so long? I mean, look at this guy. The second I saw him, I was like, that's a soup. That's like, like I said, Indiana Jones or like, you know, like he's a leading big blockbuster star. And he wears it well. He really is the same guy that he was 15 years ago.
知道，国际巨星时，你会看着他想，是的，好莱坞怎么花了这么久才发现他？我是说，看看这家伙。我第一眼看到他时，我就觉得，这就是个大腕。就像我说的，印第安纳·琼斯或者，你知道，他就是那种大片的主角。他驾驭得很好。他真的和15年前一模一样。
Yeah. He's so grounded and normal. Great guess, Sean. Nice going. I've always been crazy about him. And yeah, will, I mean, that should have been yours. I just... Oh, no, fuck off.
是的。他非常脚踏实地，很正常。很棒的嘉宾，肖恩。干得好。我一直都很迷他。还有，威尔，我是说，那本该是你的嘉宾。我只是……哦，不，滚蛋吧。
A better friend. He had talked about it. I saw him like a month ago when we were at Atlanta and we spent the day and I was like, I want to have you on and great. And I called Michael, MGT and everybody knew. But Sean was ahead of you with that. Michael and Bennett and Rob and everybody was conspiring against me again. Arm Yerv.
更好的朋友。他谈到过这件事。我大概一个月前在亚特兰大见到他，我们待了一整天，我说，我想请你上节目，太棒了。我给迈克尔、MGT打了电话，大家都知道了。但肖恩比你先下手了。迈克尔、贝内特、罗布和所有人又在密谋对付我。Arm Yerv。
Robert Arm Yerv is proud to be part of our team. Sean, so now Jason kind of made a joke of it, but what are you, are you taking that shirt out? Today, I did. I did already. I did already. What are we doing? What's dinner?
罗伯特·阿姆·耶夫（Robert Arm Yerv）很自豪能成为我们团队的一员。肖恩，现在杰森算是开了个玩笑，但你呢，你要换掉那件衬衫吗？今天，我换了。我已经换了。我已经换了。我们在做什么？晚餐吃什么？
That's an evening outfit. Dinner's going to be at home. Dinner's going to be at home. Look at it. What is it? Well, I had spaghetti, like I said, and tuna fish for lunch. Jesus. Sorry.
那是晚装。晚餐就在家里吃。晚餐就在家里吃。看看它。那是什么？嗯，我刚才说了，我午餐吃了意大利面和金枪鱼。天哪。抱歉。
No, you didn't mention the spaghetti the first time. Yeah, I did. Yeah. I had a half a tuna and then like a plate of spaghetti. And then I had a little bit of cheesecake. Wait a second. Together? Yeah.
不，你第一次没提意大利面。是的，我提了。是的。我吃了一半金枪鱼，然后吃了一盘意大利面。然后我还吃了一点芝士蛋糕。等等。一起吃？是的。
Do you have tuna fish and spaghetti together? Yeah, you just take a glass of milk and your palate cleanser. Do you have a big race tomorrow or something? Are you trying to get your carbs up or? Yeah, I know. Are you planning, are you going to be fasting? Are you going to do a, are you going on a hunger strike? No, I'm not.
你把金枪鱼和意大利面一起吃？是的，你只需要喝杯牛奶作为清口剂。你明天有大型比赛还是什么的吗？你在试图增加碳水化合物摄入吗？是的，我知道。你打算禁食吗？你要进行绝食抗议吗？不，我没有。
I'm not fasting. I'm fatting. Are your veins too clear? Is it, there's too much blood flow? So, so you're doing this, you're having, you had spaghetti and tuna, how do you top it tonight? Yeah. I got to have a salad.
我没有禁食。我在增肥。你的静脉太清晰了吗？是因为血流太快了吗？所以，所以你正在这样做，你吃了意大利面和金枪鱼，今晚打算怎么收尾？是的。我得吃点沙拉。
I got to do something healthy tonight. Cause that was helpless. So what do you think it'll be? So it'll be a wedge with blue cheese. I think it'll probably be a salad. It'll be a salad, um, just like a, like maybe a BLT salad. You mean a salad between bread? No, are you going to, no, I know a BLT salad.
我今晚得吃点健康的。因为刚才那顿太不健康了。那你觉得会是什么？大概会是蓝纹奶酪楔形沙拉。我觉得大概会是沙拉。会是沙拉，嗯，就像一个，也许是BLT沙拉。你是说夹在面包里的沙拉？不，你是要……不，我知道什么是BLT沙拉。
Are you going to go make it or are you going to go, are you going to go pick it up? Yeah, I'm going to go pick it up. Yeah, yeah, yeah. You are? Yeah. I got to eat something. Well, where we can cut this, but we won't, but where we could cut it, where are you going to pick up the salad from Jason?
你是打算自己做还是打算去买？是的，我打算去买。是的，是的，是的。真的吗？是的。我得吃点东西。好吧，我们可以剪掉这段，但我们不会剪，但你打算去哪里买沙拉，杰森？
Your lighting is fucking phenomenal. Like indie film much. So is it, is it, does Chin Chin make a BLT salad? No, um, there's a, there's a restaurant near me that makes a BLT salad. I don't understand. How do they fry his salad? How do they wrap a salad in one of those little dough pinches? They just jump on the letter and they just, they, the same thing they use for the fries
你的灯光真是太棒了。很有独立电影的感觉。所以，Chin Chin餐厅做BLT沙拉吗？不，嗯，我附近有一家餐厅做BLT沙拉。我不明白。他们怎么炸沙拉？他们怎么把沙拉包进那些小面团里？他们只是把生菜扔进去，然后他们，他们用和炸薯条一样的东西
and then they just, the basket, they scoop it up. Oh my God. You guys, I have one word to tell you. Ready? Bye. Is that it? Bye. Smart.
然后他们就用篮子把它捞出来。天哪。伙计们，我有一个词要告诉你们。准备好了吗？再见。就这？再见。聪明。
What? Smart. What? Smart. What? Smart. What? Smart.
什么？聪明。什么？聪明。什么？聪明。什么？聪明。
What? What? What? What? What? What? What? What?
什么？什么？什么？什么？什么？什么？什么？什么？
What? What? What? I'm Rob, I'm Jerv. Smart. What? Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon music or early and add free by subscribing to Wondery Plus
什么？什么？什么？我是罗布，我是杰夫。聪明。什么？我们的下一集将在下周发布，无论你在哪里收听播客，或者你现在就可以在亚马逊音乐上提前收听，或者通过订阅Wondery Plus提前收听无广告版本
in Apple Podcasts or the Wondery app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在Apple Podcasts或Wondery应用程序中。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。